- I'm stuck in the north.
Help me out, bro.
Step bro.
- Step bro.
- Step bro I'm stuck.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
(upbeat music)
- Hello you terrific,
thoughtful tremendously talented teens
and welcome to the Trash Taste episode.
- Teens.
- So I just wanted to
beat Joey's alliteration.
- Now I know how stupid
it sounds. (laughing)
- Wait, did you think
it sounded not stupid?
No.
- How did you think it sounded?
- I didn't think it sounded that stupid.
- Joey did it. He's that was a good one.
- In my head, I was like damn got bars.
How come I didn't do that.
- Bars.
- So yeah welcome to
the Trash Taste Podcast.
I'm your host for today?
Garnt and with me again, are the boys,
Joey and Connor.
- That's me, that's awesome.
- How's your week been guys?
- It's been all right.
I mean, we should be
asking you that question.
- Yeah.
- Cause you've had a...
- Are we here on a Thursday?
- Yeah we are here on a Thursday.
- So I know if you couldn't tell.
- So I know I've not
been putting Trash Taste
on the best of records recently.
We've put the streams,
we've delayed the streams two weeks
because I unfortunately got COVID
and now we've had to delay
the stream for two days now
because I got stuck in a snowstorm
because I was up in Hakaido.
- Man I can't get a dog. (laughing)
- I am playing Gaon life
and I am losing on every
role I swear to God.
Well, no, that's exactly how it felt
because I was up in Nokado
just on a trip with me and Sydney
for a good four five days.
- Yeah.
- And we were scheduled to
come back on the Monday.
And if anything happened on the Monday,
I could have come back Tuesday morning
to record Trash Tastes
because my entire life is planned
around Trash Tastes, recordings.
I'm sure your guys are
lives days now as well.
- Pretty much yeah.
- And unfortunately on Monday I woke up,
checked my flight.
My flight was canceled.
I was all right, whatever.
It's okay we can expect that to happen.
Sometimes I look on the
site to rebook my flight
and every single flight
for the entire day is
just canceled was canceled, canceled.
So,
- How bad was the storm?
- It was really, really bad.
It was,
I've obviously not had much experience
in cold weather and snow.
So this was the first
time (laughing) I never,
this was the first time I'd ever been,
I guess caught in a snowstorm.
And I remember when during the snow storm,
we had to take a taxi to the airport.
Cause all of the trains
had stopped running.
So it wasn't just planes.
We were looking at, oh,
can we take,
the Shinhan or the train
back from Hakaido to Tokyo?
Nope everything was gone.
- Which says a lot with Hokkaido. Right?
Because Hokkaido is one of those places
where it snows so often
that even just a little bit of snow
or a substantial amount of snow,
it's still yeah.
We'll just power through it.
Un Tokyo where it's 10
centimeters of snow,
stop the trains, stop everything.
- Rather UK can't imagine man,
the UK can't imagine.
I remember we constantly go through grit,
shortages in the UK because
we're just so ill prepared for
just the tiniest bit of snow.
- They always do the exact same speech.
Every time the snow, they were
why aren't the buses running?
The buses were running during world war II
and now they stop
cause of a bit of snow.
What is this?
They do this every single time.
They say, how dare the buses stop.
- The absolute state.
It's what is another country attack?
Or because nature attacks,
which all do you think is scarier
nature for sure.
- Nature definitely.
- So I remember I remember
during the snowstorm,
I had to go outside for just a few seconds
to go from my hotel front door,
to the taxi in the road in front of me,
simple one to two minute walk,
And we've all done it.
And I remember thinking
it's just a bit of snow.
It's just a bit of wind.
I've handled that before.
I go out and then I've never feltnature
is just beating the outta me just as soon
as I stepped out the door.
Because this snow I'm
I felt snow before.
It's I felt snow before.
- It's soft, it's fluffy.
- It's soft it's fluffy.
No, this snow was ice man.
The wind had turned this
soft, fluffy snow into
into a WMD or something that.
my face literally,
I felt my face was
getting cut from the brief
moment that I didn't have my hood up.
- Look the weekend album.
- Yeah.
And seeing her caught in
a Pokemon attack.
Yeah basically it this was
literally just blizzard.
(laughing) I could feel the hail,
just beating the outta my face.
- That one 20 PowerPoint.
- Oh and it was even
worse for Sydney as well.
Cause for some reason,
Sydney decided that she
shouldn't bring any footwear
to her Hakiddo other than heels.
So it was boots.
But it was boots with heels on them.
- Yeah.
- That yeah, I know.
- What!
- What was she expecting up in Hokkaido?
- I think it's just been so
long since she's seen snow.
That she has forgotten what,
other environment just (crosstalk)
- Wisconsin right?
Doesn't it snow up in Wisconsin.
- Yeah, it does.
Cause I was just ,
I remember asking her, oh,
I remember telling her, oh,
I've never seen snow this in my life.
And she was
oh, it's it's been a long time.
And I was
so it's been a long time for you.
And yet you are still so ill prepared.
- You less prepared.
- You are so ill prepared
for this weather.
But yeah we just weren't obviously
we weren't expecting it to be that
harsh weather conditions
to be that harsh so hard.
And yeah we had to stay in Hakaido
basically we were living out of an
airport hotel for two days.
Cause we woke up the next day.
I remember cause I messaged these guys.
Guys were gonna have to possibly delay
the recording by an hour or two maybe
I'm gonna get an early flight.
It's all gonna be good.
It's only the weather forecast.
It's only scheduled for
the snow to be really bad
on this day.
I wake up, I look out my window,
the Blizzard's still going and I'm guys,
so guys, okay.
I can make it back.
I swear to God.
The flights aren't council yet.
- Yeah.
- And I remember trying to reorganize
with these guys to be
okay, I'm gonna make it back on this hour.
I can make back to the
studio at this hour.
We can record.
We can still stream.
It's all good.
It's fixed guys.
We can still do Trash Taste.
And hour passes and then every
flight is canceled again.
And in the defeated manner
I text these boys going
sorry, boys I let you down.
- Wasn't so much you that let us down.
It was the weather.
It wasn't your fault.
- (laughing) Yeah.
- Just fight through it.
Don't just walk back.
It's walkable.
- Cause we've been through
Hakaido few times before
and I swear to God, every
time you go to Hakaido,
you're playing Gacha with
the planes then. (laughing)
Cause a lot of planes get
canceled very frequently.
Obviously not in this kind of state
where literally the entire
airport was shut down,
but you're normally playing Gacha
when you go to Hera
because one or two planes
will normally get canceled
or scheduled all heavily, heavily delayed.
- But then that's when you
discovered why airport,
which is the airport in
Hokkaido is so well equipped.
- Right. Yeah.
Yeah. It is actually should I say
Airports is one of the best airports
I've been to in the world.
I think really just, just,
I mean just with how many restaurants
and how many resources are there.
- It's basically a shopping
mall inside the airport.
- Yeah basically.
Cause the airports that
stick out to me are airports
Singapore airport which is just
that's an amazing airport.
The Hakaido airport is mall
with an airport attached to it.
- Yeah.
- Where most of the stuff you see
is before you go into the departure zone,
whereas most airports
it's the departure zone,
which really has all of the restaurants,
all of the shops and all
the everything, but yeah.
In Jato, I mean there's
even a cinema there as well.
- Which there was.
- Yeah.
- I did you watch something?
- I didn't, the only film were playing was
the Kyon movie.
- Do this, just go watch it.
Just go watch.
- I am actually gonna go
watch it this weekend,
which is the only reason why
I didn't watch it when I was in Hakaido.
- I see.
- But yeah it wasn't,
too bad because of the airport.
Then luckily I was able to
get a hotel at the airport.
It was just more annoying
because obviously I wanted to be back.
I wanted to be working, but yeah.
I mean there's not really
much to say about it.
I mean I'm sure this is
every other day for a
Canadian, I remember there's.
- Gonna be a million people
in the comments being whoa.
Imagine living with sort of
that every day of the week.
- Yeah, because I remember bring.
- Your own slate dogs.
How responsible you had gone.
- Yeah. It was just weird.
Just because I'm just used to,
no matter what happens,
there's always kind of a plan B
that you can fall back
on a possible plan B,
but it was just,
the roads were closed.
Airports were closed.
Trains were closed.
So I was literally stranded.
- You basically experienced quarantine.
- Yeah basically I was basically
stranded at the airport
and there was no plan B.
There was no services I could
call to get myself out of
there to a place where I could
get some public transport to.
- Did you go around getting
the shopping carts to get some
money together so you could buy a burger.
- Collecting plastic cans.
- Yeah. So yeah.
I basically just lived
the terminal except sorry.
Unfortunately I wasn't Tom hack.
- Cause I think one of the
craziest weather phenomena
I've been caught up in was
when I was in Vegas and
they have dust storms there.
- Dust storms.
- Yeah. So basically just
think of a sandstorm,
but instead of the sand coming in from a.
- I've never even been in the sandstorm.
- Well, I haven't been in a sandstorm,
but I've been in a dust storm
and it happens pretty frequently in Vegas.
- It's the difference between sand dust?
- I thought it was a sandal at first.
But then everyone, all my friends were oh,
it's a dust storm coming.
- It's a different vernacular.
- Maybe or it's maybe it's not just sand.
Maybe it's sand, another
crap, mixed into it.
But basically I was driving
around in Vegas, just
with a bunch of friends
and then on the radio,
cause he had the radio on
it just suddenly switches on
and it is oh there's a
dust storming coming.
So please evacuate kind of thing.
And I was my pants.
I was what the is a dust storm?
And then, but everyone else there,
the locals just oh yeah,
it happens pretty frequently.
Let's just go to a
restaurant gets on to eat.
Oh wow.
So we go into this and then
the dust storm hits. Right.
And it's just, yeah,
just think of a typhoon.
Right. So it's just really insane winds,
but you can't see outside.
- The whole windows are.
- Nothing.
It's just all sand.
It's just it's a blizzard,
but instead of white,
it's just grayish brown.
- It's a survival game. Yeah.
- But what's more terrifying
in my opinion than a blizzard
is the fact that in a dust storm
it can cause static electricity.
So basically you have thunder
strikes at ground level
because of all the particles
rubbing together. Right.
So every now and then it'll
just be blowing and then
you'll just hear this
boom sound from outside.
And I'm the is happening.
It's oh that's just the electricity.
I was why are you saying it?
oh yeah, yeah.
That's my friend.
so saying it so casually.
Yeah. So
- That's really interesting.
- So that entire time
I was my pants while,
we were in this ramen shop.
Of course they were oh Joe's Japanese.
Let's just go to a restaurant.
I'm yeah, yeah.
I'm here all the way in Vegas to go
eat some subpar Japanese food I bet.
So we were so basically I was stuck inside
a Roman shop called Narato.
- Are you serious?
- I'm not even fronting
it's it was called Narato.
I mean they did their best, oh yeah.
The walls had Narato, did they?
- And some of you could have been named
after the location.
- No.
It was and the ramen, it was very obvious.
They tried to replicate the Narato
amen as best as they could, right.
- To not that great levels immediately,
I think it was the most three outta
10 RO I've ever had.
So I was great.
I'm stuck inside this restaurant called
Narrato eating us.
- All this poor restaurant
getting destroyed.
- I don't think it exists anymore.
Isn't the thing.
So I'm and if it does
exist, sorry, you're that.
- Is the most perfect moment of
LO's going this guy's
Japanese, you side me.
- The perfect place that
the episode Simpsons.
And they go to America town in Japan.
- Yeah basically.
- Dude I mean the first thing,
the first thing I ate
when I went to America
for the first time,
which was the first ex I ever went to,
my friends took me a little Tokyo.
And I was bro.
- Every yeah, every time you I've got ax,
everyone to get a little Tokyo.
- I just came from big Tokyo. (laughing)
- I didn't need to go.
- A smaller variant of it.
And then I had, again, some subpar Ram
in little Tokyo, I was yeah, great.
The fan, this is the
LA experience I wanted.
- The only time I've ever seen a natural
phenomenon of is
I saw sun in the UK One time.
- You were oh I.
- Holy shit.
- I've seen fire tornado in Australia.
- What the is a fire tornado.
- We have breezes in the UK gust of wind.
- So you have tornadoes.
And you have Bush fires.
So what happens when a
tornado enters a Bush fire,
You basically get this
spiraling, pillar of fire.
- That's terrifying.
- It's awesome to look at from a distance.
- These, settlers must
have been so confused
when all this was happening.
They're what the is happening?
- British that's what the British saw the.
first time in Australia.
They're what the fuck is that?
- The first time they
found the swamp in Florida,
they're what?
- Bit humid in here.
- Australia is just a real
life island in one piece,
- A fire in Ireland.
- It's an island on the
grand line at this point.
Because the survival instincts
you need in this island,
that that's taken out most the pirates
in one piece at this point.
- Imagine being the
Geris to write the guide.
They Chan back to people
who are gonna come again.
So by the way,
you're not gonna believe this, right.
how it suns sometimes, right?
that all the time.
- All the time.
- And sometimes I don't
know how this happened.
There was just fire tornado.
I don't even know what a tornado is.
We never even seen one of them.
There's a tornado.
- It says, but it's such
a weird thing as well,
because it's not I kind of described it,
there's a Bush fire and
then a tornado comes long
and eats up the fire.
It's also the fire is so
strong that it basically
creates an up current that starts to spin.
And then it just creates
this pillar of fire that just
crashes through just, just sounds.
It's really cool to see.
- It just sounds a anime
attack at this point.
Where,
- I was like
is there a Pokemon battle
happening over there?
And someone did fire spin.
I don't know.
- There's two jujitsu being
combined together in Narato.
- This stomach after having
that narrower Ram. Yeah.
- It's cut on.
- Yeah, I did it.
I did see actually there recently,
the UK or at least London went through
a pretty bad storm.
- Bad storm, yeah.
- Which I dunno how bad it was.
'cause when I see, when I see UK.
- It looked really bad.
It looked really.
- Bad cause when I see, but
when you see UK headlines yeah.
And you see
oh UK go through a bad storm
and the strongest wind scene.
And I'm just is it
obviously it's going to be bad for the UK,
but how bad is it on a global scale?
- There, is videos about picking up people
and throwing them.
- Seriously. Oh.
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah. Cause when I saw the headline,
I thought it was just the
British over exaggerating as
no dude, as you guys, usually there's
my friend's too pay fell off.
It's an absolute travesty.
- It's so strong.
- I saw severe people get thrown around.
I was oh my God.
rip, if you're trying to
open that car door, man,
you're trying to get that close.
- Never have. Yeah.
Cause this.
So this just shows how unused we are to
these kind of weather systems
and whether phenomena.
Cause we're me
and Connor are ina group chat
of the our friends in the UK.
And sometimes, they're still meeting up
and they're still planning,
meetups and everything that.
And I saw in this group chat that,
that they had planned a meetup
or to hang out on this day.
And I remember right up
to the last moment people
were just oh yeah, I'll
see you guys in an hour.
I'll see you guys an hour.
We're still meeting in an hour and people
I'll see you in an hour.
I, and then you just
see you just see this,
the replies going, yeah.
Let's maybe not meet up today.
Maybe that's not the best idea.
But the thing is,
if this was one of the worst storms that
UK has gone has gone through,
I am also really used to the
idea that no matter what,
you can still go out and have a pipe,
you can still go out and have a pipe.
No matter.
- The pub has been canceled.
- So that's how I knew that
this storm was the real deal.
If my mates were not going
to the pub to meet up
because of this storm, gone down.
- The pub isn't closed, then
that means I can still go.
- Right. No matter what.
- It is basically that, Oh God.
That is another third
of UK people severely
unprepared for, weather systems.
- Yeah.
Because I remember,
when I first met my first British person,
from the UK who exist.
They exist I was oh my
God, you guys exist.
But second of all, they're always oh yeah,
we have nothing going on in the UK.
No bad weather, no dangerous animals.
Know nothing I'm Don really real.
I found that hard to believe as
someone who came from the
polar opposite of that.
Just call it.
I came from doom.
I came from hell basically the under one.
Because it's do you guys really not?
what is the most dangerous
thing that floods flood.
Okay.
I was about to say floods.
- We got a lot of rivers.
So obviously when it rains a
lot, it can flood back. Yeah.
Depending on where you are in the
UK there aren't floods.
- Yeah. what if you're
nowhere near the rivers.
- Yeah. Then you don't get anything.
Occasionally you.
- Guys get a lucky.
- Yeah. We've had hurricane scares before,
at least in my lifetime,
but nothing that actually
manifests anything felt
- A hurricane. Right?
- It was just a bit of strong wind.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Gust.
- Yeah. That's that was pretty much it.
Yeah. I mean, we don't have
a lot to fear in the UK,
which is why whenever I travel
abroad, whenever I, well,
sorry, I lost my train of thought.
Whenever I travel a abroad, bored.
- A abroad.
- Whenever I travel abroad, I got it.
I got it this line, there you go.
Sometimes it just surprises
me about some of the things
you have to be careful of
just because in the UK,
we don't have to be careful
of anything with camping,
you have to be careful about bears or,
starting a forest fire,
which to me starting a forest fire was
so outside a perception of what,
of disasters that could
happen from just one person.
But if you think about it yeah.
Of course it makes sense. you see,
you look at Australia
being on fire California,
half the year being on.
- Fire. Yeah.
Our country was on fire
for nine months straight
because of one guy starting a fire.
- Yeah,
Yeah. To me that's just so outside
of my perception of what could
possibly go wrong.
Of one stupid person doing a stupid thing,
- Yeah.
- So.
- Yeah. I mean, all the
trees are wet in the UK.
It was very hard to get.
Even I remember when we were camping,
it was even hard to get
trees that weren't too
D really to burn.
- Jeez. Yeah.
I mean, you could come in with a
flame thrower and it would
probably be put out by the day.
- The flame will run out gas.
- It's very rough.
I don't think we've ever
seen anywhere, in nature,
on fire in the UK.
- Really?
I don't think so.
- No, fire's just not
- It's hard to get it
started. Yeah. It's very.
- Hard to get nature fires.
Aren't a thing that we have
to be careful about in the UK.
- And yet one of the biggest
UK hits was fire starter.
So, that's bit ironic.
- It's cause they,
had so much time while
they were making the fire starter.
- They, part, I make a song about it.
- Oh God, you do the fire.
I'll make I'm.
- That's why it's an achievement.
Cause it's easy to be a fire
starter anywhere else in
the world, in the UK.
It's a medal.
- I'm a Fire starter it's You manage that.
- On some forest fires natural,
there's that needs to happen
sometimes to clear a lot
of the dead trees and stuff.
And then see a lot of
them recently are not.
- Yeah. So we have controlled Bush fires
in Australia that happens
pretty frequently because we also have,
I don't know the details about it,
but we have this specific
is it breed I don't know.
what the word for it is of tree or sapling
where breed it's a type of eucalyptus.
I think where the,
seeds from the tree, right.
Need to be put into a fire in.
- Order for.
- It to open up.
- So to keep the forest alive,
they actually have to burn these seeds
and basically start a
Bush fire for that area of
the bushland to grow in,
which is the most backwards thinking
that nature has ever done.
- I imagine if the dead trees pile up
and then it's as
hot as it is in Australia.
It'll naturally catch.
- On. Oh, fire.
We get natural bush fires all the time.
Just cause of how hot
and powerful the sun.
- Australia literally is
the last dungeon area.
even nature is high level
in Australia what the.
- Randomly just start up.
- It's literally the desert level.
Andres of the rather
the breath of the wild.
- Breath of time.
- It's literally the desert level
and breath of the wild where
if you don't have the right equipment,
you are forever just gaining damage from.
- Song. Yeah.
I think in Israel,
I think as well, I can't remember.
I might have been on one of those generic
videos where you learn about.
You didn't know, you
wanted to learn about,
and then you learn about
it and you're eh, okay.
I YouTube you mean every YouTube?
Mainly videos if always that.
So I think it was
because the US for so
long was actively stopping
all the fires.
It turned out that a lot of
the branches needed to just be
set ABL so that they
could get rid of them.
And then it could go back in the system,
it turns into Ash.
So they had a buildup
of a lot of dead trees
and stuff that. So when
the fire, I did start,
it went crazy
and it should be nearly as big as it was.
- I mean yeah, we.
- I think I could be.
- Wrong on that. Yeah.
we have so many controlled
Bush fires just because
we do have just at least in my area,
we have a lot of wildlife
and nature reserves
and stuff like that.
But sometimes, unfortunately they're not,
some of those fires aren't controlled 100%
of the way
and that's what causes
Bush fire scares and right.
You're up bush fires sometimes.
So I think that's why we have
a lot of that just because
we're trying to maintain the nature.
And then sometimes nature's what?
I'm a go ham a little bit.
And then they go ham.
- And controlled fire
in the UK is from trying
to boil your water. (laughing)
- It's oh God.
- As an Australian,
what is your guess fear
over there in terms of
nature wise, what'd,
you have to be careful
about the most emotion.
- Yeah.
- Honestly, the people scam me the most.
- That's such a video game, movie thing.
- It's not the emotion.
- Worry about kid.
It's the people,
humans are the scariest of them.
All the humans were
the monsters all along.
- You can predict a black
widow can't predict.
- A human guns don't kill people.
People kill people.
- In terms of wildlife.
I'm usually pretty okay with insects
and snakes and spiders.
If I know it's not going to kill me.
- Have you ever had a
big scare yourself of
you've encountered something you're oh,
this could actually.
- Oh yeah many times.
I've the health bar comes
on the bottom of the screen.
- Many times I remember
I was actually this close to
basically dying at one point
because I was this close to
being by bitten by one of the
most venomous ants in
the world, venomous ants.
So we not only so Australia,
so people outside of Australia
think that Australia's just
venomous spiders and snakes
that's but we have fair.
We have a lot of venomous insects
and we have this one ant species
called the bulldog ant and
it is supposedly the most
venomous ant in the world.
And I almost got bitten by
one when I was 10 years old.
- I think dark dark horse
is way more balanced than
Australia. At least it has a hip box.
You can see.
- So basically I was camping,
that's where most of the accidents happen.
So you got.
- The campfire, right?
- That makes sense. Yeah.
No, I was camping the bonfire
and I was sitting on.
- I lit the bonfire.
- I thought I was in the
safe zone and I wasn't,
- The one enemy before
I could teleport. Yeah.
So I was kind of sitting
around the fire with,
my family and my mates.
And I was maybe 10, 11 years old.
And we were ina really,
really deep rainforest area. Right?
Yeah. So it was basically
we just found a flat,
it wasn't even a registered
campsite basically.
It was just oh, we found
a flat piece of ground.
Let's just, start a fire here,
as long as it's control, it's what.
- The way he just said, you.
- Didn't say let's make this all campsite.
- Let's not a fire.
- I mean a responsible firefighter.
- Yeah. A small fire.
Let's start a fire here.
- Let's hunker down here
for the night, right?
Let's so we set up the camp there and
my dad started of the fire
and we were getting all cozy up.
And I was sitting on the
it's giant slab of rock.
Right. Okay.
Right. It was very smooth.
And asa 10 year old,
you just wanna climb. Right.
It's so it's,
I found lots of little rocks to
and big rocks to kind of climb around.
And I was sitting and
I was kind of sitting
with my mate as well.
And my hand was rested back this.
Right. Okay.
And I kind of legs out.
Kind of thing.
And I was just chilling and every
and then I felt something
crawl onto my hand. Right.
And I looked down and it was an ant,
but I was oh,
that's a big ant.
- But how big are we talking that.
- That's quite big.
- That's pretty funny.
I mean, that's still an ant.
Yeah still an ant's.
It's just this.
- This pitch black T just kind
of rolling onto my finger.
And then yeah.
And then I kind of put my hand up
and was looking at it.
And then my friend who
was next to me just gased
and then immediately swatted my hand away
and swatted this ant off me.
And I was what the?
I was looking at this cool ant.
- Oh, why.
- Why would you do that?
And he was dude, would've died.
you do know what that thing is.
And then he told me and
he showed me what it was.
And I was well, thank
you for slapping my hand.
Glad I didn't die young.
- Does it, does it
definitely kill you? Or is it
- I mean it can kill.
They say the venom is
powerful enough to kill
an adult in 15 minutes.
So as a 10 year old,
probably would've been instant kill.
- Yes what's the coyote
Peterson video of him.
- Sting test. (crosstalk)
- Kill me.
- The next level of.
- It's in the OG YouTube days, it's
will it blend 20, 30 YouTube?
Will I die?
Let's find out.
- I'm for this I'm about
to enter the death zone
with the dudu guys.
- Yeah. So yeah.
So my friend saved my life
and now I know that we have these ants.
Cause when you're a kid in Australia,
you are always, told be
careful of the snakes,
be careful of the spiders because
we do have a lot of non venomous kinds.
But that's not the ones you
have to walk out for obviously
I've been bitten by a snake once,
but it wasn't venous.
It just really hurt. So
that, I mean, that's fine.
It was just a little nip on the finger.
So it's whatever, what, doesn't kill you.
What doesn't kill you
makes you stronger. Right.
- They must have sent
the craziest from the UK.
If I was there,
one of the first people in Australia
and all my friends just
it's bitten by an end and
we're laughing jovial.
And then he just dies.
I'm like we're leaving, this place.
Get back on the boat.
We're leaving.
- Oh little cute little lamp Boom.
- It's just I get back, pack the back up,
pack it up.
- That's why they send the prisoners that.
- That's it's literally
the dark continents in hunt. (laughing)
- That's when you play
the ground is LA it's
everybody off the ground.
- History is the UK.
I don't think I'd have the
courage to do anything in
Australia cause they're no,
the more I read the more I'm just I just,
I guess I just won't go
outside cause it's great.
The beaches sound great.
Why I read about stone fish.
Right? And then I'm just oh,
- A stone fish.
- Just don't step on the way.
- So a stone fish is a fish
that looks exactly a stone.
It's very ugly fish.
- It's a very a bottom dweller fish.
- But it's fins have razor sharp needles
that if you step on it,
it's apparently one of the
most painful experiences, you.
- Can have your from an animal.
- Any of your friends stepped on one.
- I've had a friend step on one]
and he, I mean he obviously
went to the hospital for it.
He didn't die, but.
- Well that's the plus, but I mean.
- Didn't die.
- Is it venomous or is it painful?
- It's just extremely voice.
I mean, if you, it could
cause anaphylactic shock
and kill you if you're unlucky.
- It's the most venous fish known.
Yeah. It's the most venous
fish known on earth.
And so even if I don't,
even if you don't die,
you're going to have
a very, very bad time.
- You're just gonna
experience a lot of pain.
- If you're experiencing enough.
- Pain cause of the pain.
Is it sharp or is it got some poison?
- It's Probably got some toxins
in it or something, right?
- Yeah. It can kill you by the way.
- It can kill you if you're.
Just pull up the Glock
shoot your own foot.
Just stop it from going
through the cut it off.
- Off John Wicked
- I mean I think,
but things stone fish and all that are.
- Are they super common
or is it super rare?
- No, it's very, very rare.
This video is sponsored by Harry's.
- As you guys know,
I am a Sigma male
and the only thing I will allow to touch
my Sigma mail beard is Harry's.
I actually only use
Harry's I'm not kidding.
I've said it every single Harry's ad Reed.
I bought a bunch in the UK
when I came here and I still use
Harry to of this day.
- Well then you'll be happy to know Connor
and everyone watching this
video that new customers
can redeem a Harry's trial set.
Forget this $3 dollars, $3.
When you go to Harry's
dot com slash Trash Taste.
- Harry's believes you
shouldn't have to choose
between a close,
comfortable shave and a fair price.
So they give you both.
In fact, Harry's blades
are designed to stay
sharper for longer in a recent study.
Guys who shave four times a
week said that eighth shave was
as smooth as their first.
- While dear viewers and
listeners today is your lucky day.
New Harry's customers.
Yes Ken Redeemer start a set.
You had five blade razor,
a weighted handle.
Foaming, shaving gel with alloy,
with alloy
and a travel cover to protect your blades.
When you're on the go that's
$13 value boys for $3.
Oh, it's truly never been
a better time to try.
Harry's go to Harry's dot
com slash Trash Taste to try
Harry's today.
- Back to the video.
One thing you mostly have to worry about.
If you go to the beach in
Australia is the jellyfish.
- I was gonna say the second
thing that terrifies me.
- Well we have a ton of
those in the jellyfish.
- Not to take jellyfish though.
- Oh, but the ones that
areextremely painful.
- Oh yeah.
I mean, because we,
you are probably seeing
your box jellyfish, right?
Yes.
Yeah. I've never seen that in the waters.
I've never heard of anyone
getting stung by that,
but that's the one that can kill you.
And people have.
- Yeah. Where it puts you in
so much pain that you drown.
Cause you have zero control over your.
- Yeah. It basically
paralyzes you immediately.
- Have people survived.
- People have survived.
But I mean it's a very uncommon way.
Sorry it's a very rare
way for anyone to die.
I think only maybe two or
three people die a year
from it or something.
So it's very rare considering
the amount of people
who go into the ocean in Australia,
it's you gotta be really unlucky.
- Jellyfish just scare me.
- But I mean I've been stung by a,
the other kind of jellyfish
that's way more common is they
call blue bottle jellyfish.
And they're not toxic or anything.
they won't kill you,
but it hurts a lot when you get stung by.
- My friend got stung by
one where we were swimming
in some ocean.
In the UK.
- And the trick in the
Australia is if you have a mate,
who's been stung by a blue bottle.
You pee on it.
- The, I think this is one of
those rumors though. Isn't it?
This is just right by Jojo fans.
I don't think it actually does.
- I think the actual way to do it is
you gotta pull vinegar or something on it,
but may some having your
mate on you feels relieving.
- Yeah. It's some kinda
alkaline that you actually
have to put it on.
- When you say it out loud,
it does feel like a scene from Jojo.
Doesn't it.
- You've been stung by a stand.
The only thing Go.
- To the fact the treatment
is hot water apparently.
- Oh, that makes sense.
P just hot water from.
- The body scold my leg, poor.
- Boiling that's 36 degrees right there.
Dark like that.
That's warm as fuck.
- This is why this isn't
a problem in the UK.
Everyone's always got a hot
firmness ready for the teeth.
They voting to just
- Get the teeth firm.
- Put on could make it worse.
- Actually. Oh really?
Depending on how I see Wells of
sorry for peeing on your leg.
That one time.
- Well, I remember we were swimming
and a bunch of the jellyfishes washed up.
- That's normal.
Oh yeah. I've seen that in the UK as well.
- Clashed them bunch of them washed up
and this little 10 year old didn't
know what they were.
I think I was 12 dived.
- Into it. Yeah.
Just picked one up
and well you can pick them up by the head.
Yeah. No.
- He picked it up by.
- The 10.
Yeah. That's probably
immediately started crying
and screaming and.
Oh. Yeah.
- There was, I remember
there was loads of them.
I remember I got really freaked out.
Cause I was
what the is that?
This is not how they were in finding Nemo.
That's why I remember.
I didn't think there was any
fish fighting. The weird fish.
- There was, yeah, that was jellyfish
and find what's weird.
- Fish? What fish.
- Freaked me out so much
more than animals do
- Is fish, not animals.
- No fish, fish or fish right?
Animals are animals.
- Jelly, fish isn't an animal.
I know it's an animal, but what.
- Off? what?
The is going on with fish?
- I mean it, another brain and doesn't.
- Have jellyfish is just God's spunk.
That's just what it, they are it.
- Fights back.
- I mean that's the closest way.
I, the ocean sperm cell.
- It is the ocean sperm cell.
- You look at that Mr.
Incredible meme where he is smiling
and GRE you getting more sad.
It's you look at dogs.
You're yes. And then you get outta horses.
You're yes.
Yeah. Then you get so rats.
You're okay.
And then you start
getting these weird fish.
Then you're what the geeky fish.
Then you start getting
to the real weird fish
ones are all no eyes
and just all teeth.
And you what the is I putting down there?
It's like some creature.
- It is legit.
The what's going on with fish.
- What's going on?
- What, who's what is an episode of Feld?
Who's in charge.
What is that with fish?
- Who's in charge the
evolution down there.
It's out of control.
- You guys heard about
the immortal jellyfish.
- No, I listening.
So there is a species of jelly fish
that scientists believe are immortal
they cannot be killed by time by old age.
So obviously they can still
be cured by external forces,
meat and whatever.
- But that's brilliant.
But it's believed by scientists
that they are in a sense.
Immortal okay and that
scares the outta me.
That's just because
nothing should be immortal
nothing alive should be
immortal that's just a survivor
stand from past season.
- Oh they just have no age.
That is literally just the stand.
Can't die.
- Apparently they reckon
that aging is process it
cells and stuff.
It's on purpose.
- I'm not bullshitting right, Ashley?
There isn't something
called immortal jellyfish.
- Apparently it just
regresses into a pollen form
and then it go comes back against.
- Oh yeah. So it's literally
just a single cell,
organism kind of deal where it's just
forever just recreating itself basically.
- So a car accident.
Just turn back into a
baby and group back old.
- Again, that's a Benjamin button.
- Stadium that is actually
just a superpower.
That's pretty.
That's cool dude.
But could you imagine though,
if humans were able to
somehow study that enough.
And be we're.
- Trying, I think.
- And being all right,
this might actually be
the key to immortality.
- What's the point of being
immortal if you get to 60
and you're useless at 60
and you're what are you gonna
do for another 100 years?
- Well, that's why they come
progress in age as well.
Cause they just Get to
a point where they're
I can't do sports anymore.
Time to go back.
- Let's just say we can keep you alive.
Till 200 but after 50 you start
you start degrading
and then 70 you're kind of useless,
Well I'm saying,
I'm not saying all people
are useless by the way,
but you personally can't do what you want.
- Right.
Is the point of you
being another 130 years
now the 100 years?
what's are you gonna do?
Just catch up with the
rest of Game of Thrones.
- That's why I remember,
in future drama episodes.
when they have all those old
celebrities from centuries
that go just as heads in Europe.
And I remember one of
my friends was oh man,
it wouldn't it be cool if
we humanity got to that,
that point in technology.
I'm no, what do you want?
That would be horrible.
You'd just be sitting on a
shelf for the rest of human.
the rest of yeah.
Time, rest of time.
Rest of time, just doing what?
How do you have fun?
How'd just, yeah.
You just head in a jar, I guess.
I'll don't know. Perfect.
Beatboxing or something
that's that's all you can do
as a head.
- Just there's that trick right?
With the cherry stem where you can tie up,
what else you gonna do?
- Wow this perfect a Jojo.
- Learn languages, I guess.
- For the rest of time, learn
every language in the world.
Yeah. Probably or just, or
just watch out, think about it.
There is a few things you can do
or just watch Pokemon in your mind.
- Yeah, exactly.
The ultimate life back.
Oh, what are you doing?
I'm just watching the
6,003 run of Pokemon.
I guess it's a really
philosophical question of if you
could be immortal would
you want to be immortal
and I'm just
I wouldn't want to be
maybe I wouldn't want to
die at say 80 or 90 or whatever,
but there's a point where
I would my body to keep up.
- With what I want to
do. Right. Okay. Well on.
- Well then different question.
How old, if you could choose,
how old would you want to be when you die?
- I, to me, it depends
on how functional I am.
Yeah. Cause I, yeah.
I've met 90 years old,
90 year olds who are
still in tip top shape.
And I've also met, 60 year olds
who have trouble doing things that I would
want to do do as well.
- My fifties Man.
- Yeah it depends on
how lucky you get rid.
- Yeah, some of my friends,
they're some of their
dads 55 already getting
dementia and stuff.
It's scary. I would hate to get there,
especially if my kids are young,
I don't want them to feel yeah,
they gotta help me out.
- I think the cool dancer was my granddad,
apparently in his twenties, ,
from his twenties, he was like
I'm gonna die at age 80.
Just no cap.
And for the longest time I was
why would you say that from a young age?
And he's because it gives me a time limit
to do all the things I want
to do before I die.
And so it's self the motivating. Yeah.
And this is how much of
a Chad, my granddad was.
He died exactly at a 80.
And he was literally I'm,
I'm good, man.
- I'm good to go.
I allowed ask how.
- Oh, you died from lung cancer but.
- I was gonna say that this man, well,
how did it go there?
- I mean, the thing is though, I think.
- It sounds did everything
in one of the, yeah.
- He was literally on
his 80th birthday, he was
I can go now with no regrets.
- Just waiting for the clock to.
- Ready to pull, ready to pull the plug.
- So but I thought that was so cool.
Because there's that
very common philosophy of
if you became immortal
you would do nothing
because you'd have no rush.
- You'd have no drive to.
- You have no drive to do
the things you wanna do.
Because you can do it whenever you want.
So I, yeah.
that's my reasoning for
why I wouldn't wanna be.
Immortal also I don't know.
I don't wanna see everyone around me die.
That should be so funny.
Well, if you live in a
society where everyone can
choose how, when they.
- So if we were living
in an immortal society,
is that what.
- You're saying in society?
We if we lived in a society.
- Then I think we just
regress to the stone age
at that point.
Cause no one would wanna do anything.
- Yeah.
I mean for me, personally,
I find the badass people
are the people who live
till the late, their late ages
and they they seem fit.
They seem able,
and then one day they just
decide to their body just
decides all right, peace out.
Yeah. that's the way I would want to go.
I don't want the 10.
- I don't think everyone wants to go that.
But life is brutal.
- It is I think it's the teal Osama,
the guy who basically popularized manga,
he died while drawing
manga in the hospital then.
And I'm that's so badass.
The fact that this man,
literally till the
moment he died was doing
what he wanted to do.
- God's gonna be doing that final 10 pole.
- I need one more.
Just he gets 10 SRSS and he's Connor's.
- Gonna be on jump king 20.
- On the final jump.
- It gets to the top credits.
- No, but yeah.
'cause my grandma right
now is still alive.
And she's in her late nineties right now.
And I remember when I
introduced her to Sydney
for the first time
and I remember I was telling Sydney, oh,
she's in the nineties.
- I think you've
definitely told this story.
- If I told this Trash Taste,
I think you have okay.
Maybe I don't know, have I.
- I don't unfortunate Do a cliff notes.
- Okay. So yeah.
My grandma squeezed took
Sydney's hand and squeezed it.
She squeezed it so hard
that Sydney was rith in pain
for a good hour.
Cause of how hard she squeezed it Jesus.
And yeah that was a cliff
notes with the story.
Cause I think maybe I have
told this on Trash Taste.
- So basically your
grandma's a gig get shot.
- Have you not heard the story?
I think so.
- Seem familiar, I can't see.
Sometimes you can't tell
if I've told you this
at a bar or something,
I've on the podcast.
Unfortunately we talk a lot.
Unfortunately we do talk a lot.
- I saw a recent comment on
one of the Trash Taste episodes
being it's so impressive.
How the boys still to find topics that
they've never talked. I don't.
- Even know I'm yeah.
I don't even know.
- I just talk.
And sometimes we get caught out for it.
Sometimes I don't know.
- It's whatever.
- Definitely been talking
about up fish in the ocean.
I know that. Have we?
No, we haven't.
- Oh we haven't. No haven't.
- There's so many up little fishes.
- What's the animal that
scares you the most.
- Man. No, Jerry mars.
- I think, those tea lists of animals
that I could take in a fight.
- Yeah.
- I don't know why.
I just think a deer would just me up.
- I mean they could.
- Yeah.
I think I'd have more chance
of being able to outwit a
bear or something or being able to.
- Know about that.
- I would rather take on the deer than
the bear much.
What's not deer's the one with the ma.
- Barky has taught me anything
don't fuck with bears.
- Which are the ones
with the massives there,
the deers they all deers.
- Deer moose I don't know.
- I know, maybe moose,
but there's some of them
caribou I've seen some of
them that are insane.
They well, I mean, moose are insane.
how big, people imagine moose and they're
oh yeah that's just a big deal.
Right, I'm no, they're.
They're huge Insanely huge it's scary.
- I even though I think I
there's a 0.1% chance that I
could live with a bad encounter.
I at least think that Ia idea.
I'd have zero if it wanted to kill me,
I feel it would just.
- Chase what.
- What logic are.
- You this?
- The way it looks.
Are you the way it looks at me?
I don't know why.
- I'll be talking.
- You're talking about
the deer from princess Mo.
- Okay they gotta look
in their eyes dears.
They gotta look in their eye
that says I'm out for blood
and I'm not gonna be happy.
- What you talking about?
Deer's the cutest.
All the times. Have you never been in a,
You can feed the deers.
- They're no,
Those are wimp, deers.
Chad. Chad deers.
Have you seen those deer?
Is when they're wrestling
each other formating purposes.
- Yeah.
Do they let's just say
if one of these deers
thought I was gonna
steal its GF, I'm done.
it's I'm dead.
- Think you can say that
about most animals though.
if you were if you tried
to steal a,(laughing)
If you wanna go to a frat party,
I'm sure you'd feel the same
way this guy's gonna me up.
- I remember there's there's stories.
- What logic are you?
This there's absolutly zero logic.
Just the way it looks.
- So are you saying that you
can't take on a male deer,
but you could take on say a male elephant
Or a male giraffe.
- What would we say?
Take on an elephant.
Are you saying beating it?
- Well, I mean, you were
saying tear a list of animals.
I could beat in a fight, right?
- Let in the fight or survive.
I reckon I could get away maybe.
- For a bear.
And let's say you're a cave man.
And you need to take on one
of these animals, survive.
- I'm trying to kill it.
Am I trying to run away?
- You're trying to survive.
- I, yeah. Okay. I
think, I don't know why.
I just fell a deer could
chase me to the end.
The, I fell a bear might get most.
- Animals. No, a bear will
get bored after a while,
it'll get bored.
I feel a deer clearly.
- Never encountered a bear in his life.
- Let's say I climb a 20 foot tree.
I know bears and climb trees,
but I reckon the deer
somehow would just jump up.
me up Naruto style something.
I don't know why.
I'm just scared of these deers, man.
These big deers that are tigers liars.
Do you have a.
- I don't even I'll take a tiger wrong.
- Did you have a childhood
trauma grab deer or.
- Is this just the British in you talking?
- Do we even have deers?
- Of course we have deers in England.
- Are you sure about that?
Don't look at me.
- Do we have deer?
No the big deers with the analysts.
- What's the difference.
- What are the,
ones with the horns that are not,
they're all kind of spiky.
- Are you talking about caribou?
- I don't know what
they're called. Regular.
- Deal of spike handle. I know.
- Spike handles the ones with weird shape.
I'm talking about Bambi, right?
- No.
The ones with no horns aren't scary.
Why would they be scary?
They have no horns gone.
Horns are scary.
- But they also do.
- I'm not scared of rhinos.
- I'd be terrified of a rhino.
Are you kidding me?
- Just ride it.
Don't on country.
It I get on the back of a rhino, right?
What's it gonna do fall the gram.
I'll just jump off it in it.
- What about a Ram?
- A Ram I've been with a Ram.
I befriended the Rams. We will.
- So you don't find Rams scary?
- No they just kinda little Ram.
They just kinda drama Queens.
You can talk to them.
- You can talk.
You can't, you can't really can't.
- Can't with the deer these one?
- This just regular whitetail gear.
It's just a deer, right?
- Those would you up.
It's just a male.
- Obviously you pale bro.
You'll be in the tree that.
- I'm not get up the not
saying they won't you up,
but I'd rather take on that than a bear.
- Why as well, because when
you see you think it's cute,
right? You think, oh, it's cute.
And then it stabs you. Right?
A bear you're not getting
anywhere near that.
You're cautious, right?
It's about the perception.
- No, I'm not going anywhere near a
thing that has horns that.
- Well, they taste good though.
So I'd understand why you might.
- Go near it.
So if bears tasted good, would you.
- Maybe we'd have to.
I fell a, okay.
This is, why is a sense of danger?
Dictate how good the animal tastes?
- Listen, this is one of
those things where it's just
it's gonna make me look
stupid, this argument,
but it's just pure, gut.
this is no logic whatsoever.
This is just my gut for.
- So wait is dear, T for you STI scary.
- STI will you up and
you didn't expect it.
Bear is at, cause I know,
I know it's gonna me up,
but also it might not.
It might get bored. It
might just leave me alone.
- What but way are you getting this idea?
That deers are so aggressive?
- I've seen videos, man.
- Yeah. Videos of bears
being aggressive probably.
- Because some dumb is
provoking a deer, right?
yeah, of course gonna get off.
- I don't know.
I just think that bears are, friendly.
- Cause my experience with most deers,
even ones that is that you goin a 50 again
in a 50 meter radius.
- Immediately not I am not
trying to make any sense.
This is all just gut.
- You're not, you're.
- Not making sense.
I know it doesn't I know
this doesn't make any sense.
- Why we're trying to glean
some senses out of it,
but time guess is scary.
But also the tiger king seemed
he had a good hand of it.
So maybe.
- I mean it is
he slapped them with his
stick and theyover him.
So maybe if I just give him
a little, get off, stop that.
- Stop that was the problem with all
the pre that you said
weren't they weren't oh,
I'll use the.
- Slap message.
You didn't have a big enough stick.
obviously everyone most dangerous bear.
Is it the red one?
The red bear is that.
- Black grizzly bear. Isn't it?
The black one.
- Black one.
- Polar bears.
- Oh yeah. Polar bear.
- There was story from that.
I think Brian blessed, Don Brian blessed.
There's a very famous British guy.
He's this really famous
British guy who has yes.
It's the most booming voice this, right?
Yes and apparently he
was in the Arctic filming
something and a polar bear came up
and I think that he either punched the
polar bear in the face or he
screamed at the polar bear
and it ran away skit this story.
So I'd to think that I could,
if it is true that you could
scare a polar bear from
shouting at it.
I think I'll be.
- All right Well, I mean, Bucky has 50.
- Bucky has taught me that
the best way to beat a bear is
to punch it in the nose.
- I heard that you
could punch it in Theon,
the grizzly bear point.
- Yeah. Well, if you're
fast enough, right?
- I mean, not fast enough.
- I mean, at that point.
- You, like it.
- You could just, at that point,
you're kind of playing GA with your life.
- It's the same thing with sharks, right?
If you punch a shark in the nose,
then it'll just be is that.
- Is that true?
- I don't know.
I would try.
- I'm not gonna try it, but
nature's the wall.
- Slows punch the water.
- Punch literally giving
them a weak point.
I punch the shark for massive punch it.
- Where are you gonna punch a deer? Huh?
You can't punch it anyway.
It's got big spikey things.
- I feel you could
Dodge at the last moment.
- You can devil back that.
- No, the bear is too big.
The bear is too slow.
You can Dodge the bear.
- Well, you talking
about bears are fastest.
What have you.
- Seen the bear? Huh?
This is the most dumb
conversation we've ever had back.
I'm at the corner.
You're so if you see your bear,
a grizzly bear, you are
not running away from that.
- You can't outrun a bear.
- But the best tactic is that
you can now run your mates.
- Maybe I can shout at it.
Ask it kindly to talk it's nah.
- Okay. Let's have,
why don't we ask
survivors of bears, right?
What they did to survive the bear.
- I'd like to ask how
many bears survivors do
There's gotta be a few out there.
- I'm pretty sure there.
- Survivor dear survivors.
There are zero.
- Yeah, because no one talks about it.
Cause everyone becomes dear.
Cause they know if they talk,
The deer's gonna come back for some.
- The deer comes back with his family.
- You'd Beni, you'd be snitching.
- Talking up it's how many
horror movies are there
with deers as the main monster.
- People are too scared to
talk about deers open the next,
when's the next deer coming
out in the Godzilla trilogy
or whatever, man.
- DI's also dear king Kong converse,
king Kong and Godzilla versus deer.
They need to tag team the
ultimate monster deer, man.
It can go run super fast launch
itself in with those hooks.
you're done Gigi.
- So would you say the deer
is the most powerful animal?
- It is the most powerful animal.
- Spiritually.
- If we were to animal battle Royal,
would you pick deer?
- No.
- Who would you pick for an animal battle?
Royal animal kingdom. Battle royal.
I'm definitely polar bear for.
- Sure. I feel you are
going for low hanging crew.
I feel there's probably
something stronger.
- Well, yeah.
Cause I'm trying to win.
- I feel there's probably better animals.
I maybe if you asked TSSU guy I'm Boris.
I don't think so.
- Okay, the only reason
I say this is because
I literally saw a video where a polar bear
tried was starving.
Had to eaten for a while.
So he was trying to hunt
and he comes across these,
this group of wares.
I dunno what the proper word is.
The a herd Ori Sai.
And he literally tried
totried to take a bite out
of any wars.
And the hides were so thick that he, that
he couldn't grab on.
And the wars just shook him off.
And he tried with several war wars
and he just failed.
So maybe it's wars that are at
the top of the figure chain.
And we just never thought about.
- The honey badger.
That one's a scary one that one's like a,
I think the polar bear would
destroy the honey badger.
- I don't know, man, honey.
- I mean human versus honey badger.
The honey badger is probably gonna win.
- But cause I don't wanna
with a honey badger.
- What is a honey badger?
- It's a Badger that eats honey.
- No.
- No it's.
- Yes it is primarily honey.
I thought it it yeah.
- Because isn't the whole, that crazy.
Isn't the whole thing of
it with a honey badger.
Is that its height is
so thick that a beasting
literally can't penetrate it.
- I dunno. That's why
they're so that crazy.
- I remember I read something.
- About man shrimp, Manti shrimp.
- I know Manti.
- About it.
- Yeah. My God that.
That's what nature's cool.
- See fish, it's always fish.
what's going on?
- Man, shrimp is the bulky of the sea.
- Why does this fish
have a cannon for an arm?
what's going on with that?
- So it's not big.
I'm just gonna throw a fist
and create a Sonic. Boom.
- What happened with evolution?
What's go I'm telling you
man evolution in the sea is.
I don't know what's going on.
When is the next stage above that?
It's oh I throw a punch
and a nuclear fusion happen
With my fist.
- Yeah. I mean, if you
sliced up a Manti strip,
I think it could possibly create a vacuum.
That Sucks.
The air and sucks his opponents in.
- That's what Bucky should
have done instead of imagining
a human size praying Manti.
He should imagined a
human size Manti shrimp.
We had a real challenge.
- Human size Manti shirt.
Bear's dead one shot oh yeah, of course.
It's gonna be the one punch man.
Yeah, of course.
Why we talk to you about this again?
- One punch man of the sea.
- What?
One thing that I always there's
I think this is YouTube videos
where people kind of go
to nature and they're save
the animals that are
being hunted or something.
I other animals.
Right. And then they ask
David borough questions.
do you ever feel you should
help the animal that's
being hunted and stuff?
And he's no, it's literally nature.
Why would I interfere?
Don't understand why people
always make these videos being
today we're gonna save
the fish from being eaten.
It's that's literally the point fish.
- It's literally called a food chain.
- We're just sympathetic cause
we're at the top.
- Exactly, if we're in the middle of that,
see you dude.
- I'm trying to save my own life now.
- I don't think caveman
really worried about
what nature was doing.
Cause we were trying our best to survive.
- As well.
That's a Seagul being
what I'm gonna save these fish today.
Cause I feel bad.
It's no, they don't give a.
They're gonna eat.
This episode is brought to
you by call of an a beautiful
and well-crafted casual gaming experience.
- Call of anti is the perfect
stress relieving game with fun
and laid back match three RPG gameplay.
What better way to unwind
than to match those threes
and to collect yourself over 60,
be beautiful designed heroes.
- Call of AIA has a ton
of rich gameplay modes,
majestic scenes, legendary
figures, dragons, castles,
and exciting adventure.
All my Lord.
It even has online battle
modes and of events,
which you can participate
in to win free items.
- And in addition to those,
you also get free daily
summons of legendary heroes.
The free daily summon hero
featured now is Morgan.
A dashing four star legendary pirate hero
who can inflict scurvy on her enemies
by a touch of her sword.
So download call of anterior
today by using the Lincoln
description down below or
conveniently scan this QR code on
screen right now to download it.
- But gentlemen, hold on
because the first 300 users
who use our promo code
Trash Taste will get a
special reward package,
including get this.
- What Joe, tell me.
- 200 Gems.
- 30 Plus energy points.
- 30 energy points.
- And 30,000 gold.
Oh, all of that to kick.
Start your profile off in style.
Thanks again callant for
sponsoring this episode
back to the show.
- I guess I'll bring it up now.
I just Googled the most
dangerous animals in the world.
And obviously you got
you got your normal ones,
stone fishes on there.
Box jellyfishes on there.
black member, all Australian,
all the Australian ones.
Then you get the number
to number two mosquito.
Of course that. Oh yeah.
That does make sense.
Got a, big kid.
- You're not number one humans.
- We are we've killed everything.
We're awful trust.
Not even yourself.
- What's the strongest
animal you genuinely
wholeheartedly think you could,
beat in a fight.
- What define beat in a fight.
- Face to fish.
Because the animal are gonna be
oh there's no.
- Yeah bring into
submission kind of thing.
what are we talking about?
I don't know,
- Or run away, the animal runs away.
- Or it, or knock it.
- Out's a fight of fight to the death.
- Fight for some reason you're.
- In a ring.
Are we allow tools?
- No, just your bare.
- Just your bare fist.
And whatever's laying around on.
- The ground. All right.
I got it.
Realistically dog human.
Why are you.
- Fighting a dog chair?
- Human or human?
- So's dog leader STRs.
- Not that I would.
- No a big if we're not counting humans,
a big dog is probably the max I can go.
Cause even then it's scary.
- A big dog would beat you up.
- Actually I mean a big dog.
- Really big dog.
- Yeah. It could really hurt me.
- Stick on a Wolf.
I mean, it'll be hard,
but I feel if you are fighting to.
- The movie, for sure.
Yeah, I feel you could take on a Wolf.
Not it's not a guaranteed win.
But that's on the edge of
what I imagine if I was
fighting for my life is.
- Is 100% success rate.
No, but could I possibly get
a WARF into a choke hold or
something go UFC on his then
maybe if I had the right techniques,
all I'm saying human war
versus war in the Oxycon
I'm just
learn some BJJ, learn some B Jay,
maybe you might have a
more fighting chance.
- I think your dad got.
- Yeah. I think your dead.
- Cause how small do you think a Wolf is?
It's pretty big.
- You could take on a sheep.
Maybe you're gonna beat up a sheep.
- Beat up a sheep.
Not that I would want to.
- I don't think the
sheep would even fight.
No I think she would just be just take me,
Just take me away right now.
- What about you con what about you?
- What is the absolute
max that you would think
okay, I could survive this.
- Catfish could take a catfish.
- A cat up.
- I mean, No.
- The actually big one.
I've seen videos,
people getting knocked out by catfish.
They jump out of the boat.
I don't even know.
I never really think at it.
I don't think about this either.
- Maybe a very, there's some tiny monkeys,
very small monkey.
Very small monkey.
Maybe they probably gimme a good fight.
- Oh yeah. Definitely.
It'd be three rounds at least of.
- Course con says monkey.
- It'd be monkey versus monkey.
- Wouldn't it?
- Of course some of the
weaker gene of monkeys.
- On the weaker ones,
- Species of monkeys.
- Could you take on a Chimp?
- Nerve chimps, chip.
Well chip or murdery.
- Okay. Why are birds so sassy?
- What do you mean by sassy?
- They just have attitude.
What so many I've seen, they.
- Fly I mean, come on.
- I would be SASY to, if I would.
- Be an, if.
- It's literally looking
down at you. Yeah.
It's, but it's
you the birds are prey.
Aren't the sassy ones.
It's the domesticated, the
small, the small, the bird.
- The parrots, right?
- The parrots it's powers
are sass as my God.
Well, so they freak me the cow.
Cause their voices.
How do they do such an
accurate representation
of pretty much every sound.
- Our family used to own a
couple of different species of
a cockatiel anda Laura KES and stuff that.
And yeah. Sorry.
Something Keer recommended yesterday.
That was par was key.
Witness it murder trial as woman
is convicted of killing husband.
- There's 11 Million views.
- Well, what is the Paris?
Just she did it.
- Talking to par helped finger a killer.
- You heard right.
- Over five year old.
Mark Durham.
- Was found shot to death at his home.
- That's crazy.
His wife was also found.
- Shirt with a gunshot with this.
Par was they were both victims.
I mean, that's pretty cool.
I mean yeah cuzmy,
my parrot used to replicate sounds
that we would teach him.
But he would also just pick
up sounds through osmosis.
I've told this story how smash?
- No, you haven't told this.
- Okay. So we used to own this te,
which is do what a Cockatiel is?
So it's sassy as.
- Well, sassy mother.
But yeah, cause they're parrots.
Sothey replicate a lot of things.
Sowe taught it to whistle
the Adams family theme song.
So every, we'd wake up in the morning
and it'd just be,
whistling the Adams fan and everyone was
oh that's so cute.
But then other times the sassiness
would pull through on
this and he would replicate Sam on that.
Confused the out of us.
So he perfected the
sound of the microwave.
Not just he would replicate
the buttons, presses perfectly.
So he'd be beep beep
- Beep but then
when it's finished and it goes beep.
- Beep it would replicate that perfectly.
So many times.
I'd be in the living room
and I would hear that
and I would walk into the living into
the kitchen thinking that
someone was there.
No one's there. I'm oh
my God, it's a ghost.
And then I realized it's
my it's my sassy bird.
And also it would
replicate the phone ringing
and show that.
- They're really smart.
And it would also replicate
my mom saying good morning.
So it'd be it'd just be
- I'd love it to go. Yeah. Can.
- Oh, that's what I should have taught it.
If I ever get another
Laura kid, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna teach it to go.
Just to see how well it
could replicate that.
- Oh my God.
- I remember there's some
YouTube video where people
mix it badly and they put
beeps in it for some reason.
And when I'm in the other
room and It he videos playing
and I hear a beep,
I'm what's happening in my kitchen.
What's I hate people who
do use beeps really loud
beeps in their YouTube video.
Just shouldn't do it.
- I dunno I was gonna,
I thought you were gonna go a
different direction with that
conversation cause I was
gonna talk about base boosted,
monster zinc memes.
- How are you going to transition to that?
- I wanna hear how this.
- Happened because you were
talking about people putting
sounds in YouTube videos and stuff that.
And I'm just yeah, I get it.
Ion a tangent.
I still think the funniest thing,
one of the funniest videos
is just people who take the
bass boosted monster zinc theme.
- You love.
- It and throw it into
someone sleeping or something
to me that is just peak comedy.
I dunno. I just wanted to
bring back the monster
zinc bass boosted memes
thats all I literally.
- Had nothing to do with the conversation.
And I was playing.
- Your mind is just here about
bass music, monster thing.
- I was playing fived chess,
trying tolerate these two things.
- You were playing fived chess.
We were playing checkers over here.
So not even the same game.
- Anyway enough about animals.
What have you guys been
up to in the past week?
- I built a PC and it didn't work.
- Oh yeah I saw you a
Twitter thread on that.
That was pretty sad.
- So what happened with that?
- So I was building it live,
which was more stressful than less time,
I think less time because we,
did it three times rip Gar he went first.
Joey went first.
- I went first.
So doing it live was really
annoying cause I was actually
reading chat when I just
shouldn't have read chat.
Because chat kept saying yes or no.
I'd be is this the right thing to do?
Half says yes.
Half says no.
- Well shouldn't you
already know you've built.
- It used to be the PC master, right?
- Yeah you've already
built a PC live one camera.
- Yeah I pretty just done it,
but I just kept getting confused
and then when I get confused,
I get nervous.
Cause I'm live and I'm what
if I do something wrong?
And then everyone sees that I did wrong.
Cause people are laughing.
So I wasn't.
- That the whole point.
- On, but I wasn't really worried
when it was my turn doing it
live cause I'd already
seen two people build it.
So it was really easy.
Right.
- Last she'd been more stress.
There was a speed run as well.
- Yeah. And but it was okay.
It was okay.
I still some things up.
I had the MDOT two. I
had trouble with a guy.
- That MDOT two man.
- You flock with that.
I built this whole thing.
I spent five hours doing it cause I, yeah.
I up and was wasting a lot of time
and doing much of other
stuff and I was preoccupied.
So I finally built it to
five hours. Eh, turn on.
- Did you find out why or why?
So it's working now.
I have it.
So the next day I gave up,
it was1:00 AM and I tried to boot it
and it wasn't working.
And I was all right, fine.
I'll give it a go tomorrow.
I'll have a clear head.
I'll try all the problems.
I basically took it all apart
and rebuilt it all again,
going very carefully through it all.
And the same era kept happening.
And I was what?
I even took the CPU
out, put it all back in,
made sure I did all that.
Right, I just could not
figure out what was happening.
Cause it wouldn't go to the boot screen.
It was just black screen.
But everything, everything
was whizzing and
glowing and all that.
And I was oh. So then
I'm talking to gigabyte
and I'm Hey, what's happening?
Why isn't it working?
Everything is working.
Why is happening?
- And so essentially, because
I got a new specification,
it was a motherboard that is
a DDR five Ram motherboard
right now to those who don't
know anything about PCs,
basically every now and then
they upgrade it and they're Hey,
why don't we just change the
connectivity to with everyone?
And it does make it faster as well,
but they change the specifications.
You have to buy specific things.
Now this Ram slot that
was called DDR five.
I was oh, okay.
I'll go on Amazon and buy DDR five Ram.
Well, apparently that's not
what you're allowed to do with DDR
five because it's new.
Oh, motherboards have a
set list of specific DDR,
five Ram that works with it.
So not all Ram.
So previously I think DDR four,
all Ram basically worked
with all DDR four,
I think kind of.
I've never mostly, nearly all of it.
It was ubiquitous you'd have
to try real hard not to do it.
So then I was oh, okay.
Is that the issue?
It must be.
So I ordered this new Ram
plugged it in, worked perfectly.
So I wasted two days.
I was a hold extra day
trying to fix this thing
for no reason.
- That's the thing about
building PCs sucks to me.
- I'm never building.
- Another one. To me I feel to me,
the hardest to me,
the hardest part is actually
selecting the parts. Right.
Because building a PC, we said,
it's frustrating, but you can it's,
you can get through it.
It's Lego.
- PC picker as well.
- Did you actually to.
- Check for compatibility issues?
And it also wasn't compatible.
It was yeah.
It's all good.
So it's all good.
Go ahead.
- Go ahead.
You got your, I.
- I mean, it's things that.
That scare me cause I
remember the first PC I built,
the biggest thing that went
wrong was that I had bought a
motherboard that was not
compatible with the CPU because I
bought a, I bought an Intel CPU.
So I was just okay,
this me being a PC building Virgin.
I was, I got, I bought the motherboard.
I saw it was Intel compatible.
Not knowing at the time that
there are different types of
CPUs and different types of chips.
- That happened to me as well.
I had the motherboard as well.
The cooler doesn't fit,
but I just kind of shoved it in place
and it now it's working.
- That's that's scary.
- It's working.
- Was, this the first
PC you built in Japan
or just the first one ever.
- Third in Japan.
- Yeah I built four PCs in my life.
- How did 20 mine?
- Oh, five.
- And you still somehow
found a way to it up.
- Again I went to PC park
picker and it said it was okay.
So I had faith in PC park picker
cause in the previous four
times I've never had an issue.
But what happened was is that
the cooler they sent me was
one that was a bit older.
So it didn't include
the adapter bracket to Mount the CPU.
But this thing had sliders.
So I kind of slid them in the middle,
which they were, they,
you could tell that
things didn't wanna be,
and then I screwed it on.
But it works it all feels good.
It all feels secure.
Did you call Chris?
- I didn't.
- Could have done in 15 minutes.
- Helped you everyone was call Chris.
I'm what?
So he can tell me how
his McDonald's takes.
- Can he talk about his Mac?
- Yeah, it's pretty.
I sure he did a live stream yesterday
and he was just eating McDonald.
- I saw that and I was Chris,
this is not what I
normally eat for breakfast.
And I was what live?
Sorry, Chris, have you.
- Speaking of breakfast?
So since okay as you guys,
as you guys know,
I've been ona little
bit of a diet recently,
because gained a lot of weight.
When I went back to England.
- I wouldn't exactly say recently
you've been on a diet for
a while now.
- Cause here's what happens. Right.
I go on a diet fora month,
have a week holiday either with the boys,
with Sydney pig out a bit
sounds gain on gain a bit
more weight so I'm still
I go back to the diet after I'm back.
It's this sounds
- A healthy lifestyle.
I don't think it's a diet.
I think you should eating healthy.
- That's not a diet.
- I am eating healthy,
but I am definitely taking
in less calories than
it would take to maintain weight.
So I'm not this isn't a speed run,
but it's a slow lose weight gain a
little bit back.
- It's a slow run.
And yeah, the reason is when
I went back to then literally in
September or something,
I gained a ton of weight because
I ate and I drank every day.
And I thin kit was the
first time that I could
physically feel my body had gained weight
so much that I remember,
I saw a few comments
of the before and after
Trash Taste recording after
I came back Trash Taste recording.
I think you can see that.
I definitely, I definitely did.
I wouldn't say Overweight
or anything close to that,
but you could definitely see,
I did gain a little bit of weight.
So I've been working to,
since that won holiday,
working to lose that weight.
And now that I'm taking in
lower calories every day,
I'm doing things that
I wouldn't normally do,
having breakfast because normally I just,
normally I, what are.
- You off functioning member of society.
- Now? I know.
Right. I know.
Right. I never.
- Eat breakfast getting on his
high horse. I eat breakfast.
- Yeah. So because I'm
taking less calories,
I've been getting hungry in the mornings.
And so I'm oh, okay.
Maybe, it's time to start
being a normal person.
everyone else in society
and start having breakfast.
people people to talk about.
- You been enjoying it?
- So yeah, cause.
- That doesn't sound you're enjoying it.
- I mean, it's not so much I'm enjoying
it so much as I'm eating
because my body craves something
inside my stomach because.
- That's usually what hunger is.
- That is what hunger is.
- I don't get hungry at all when.
- I wake out.
No I mean, either.
- I never used to how
I start having salads
and low calorie meals every day.
And then I started getting
hungry in the morning.
It's weird.
I only feel hungry in the
morning when I'm on a trip.
But when I'm at home, I don't.
- Actually no on a trip,
even on a trip.
No really?
- Except if it's McDonald's
breakfast that's the only
breakfast I always got time.
- No one of them vacation.
I'm four meals a day sounds.
- About right. Yeah.
Let's just eat.
Let's should eat.
Exactly, why stop?
I wake up at7:00 AM in a hotel room.
I'm why am I so hungry?
That's not normal.
- So me and Sydney have
been starting to eat cereal.
And I remember as I've
added cereal to my diet,
if you've been following my Twitter,
you'd know what I'm about to say.
But I remember eating the cereal one day
and I'm just oh no,
I'm about to have a food take.
- And brace yourselves.
- I think I'm about to
have an opinion guys.
And I realize, I think cereal
is better without milk.
Oh God he said it.
Oh, he said it and.
- I'm 50 50 on this.
He said it. I like it with and without.
- And I remember just eating one day
and I just said it casually to Sydney.
And she looked at me I
just murdered someone.
She just dropped the spoon.
- She dropped the spoon in the milk.
- Is that really that bad of a take?
- I mean, apparently it is.
- weer bits in the UK as a kid.
I used to just eat those dry.
- I think, because.
- I can understand that because
when you put that in milk,
it just turns into wet cardboard. Yeah.
- But I think it's better without milk.
I think that that's what angers people's.
- It's my mood, some days I want cause
it's a challenge having to
eat cereal without milk.
It is,
- It's like you're eating Scooby snacks.
- Well your dental workout is insane.
- Well I hate it when
you pour the milk in.
And then the timer starts.
- Just pour less than you
need. Just pour less milk.
I just pour less than I need.
- How much milk are you putting in?
- No, I'm putting in the
normal amount of milk,
but it's well clearly or not.
- You're not.
It's getting wet.
Well, it's getting soggy.
I hate soggy cereal.
- You should put a little
bit in and then mix it,
force it through the milk technique.
- But I also think that
waters it down as well.
You're having cinnamon
crunch or something and then
you I want the cinnamon crunch.
I want the crunch and
the cinnamon together.
But you put the milk in.
- You wouldn't putting
more milk water down.
Wouldn't putting more milk water.
- Out there no that's what I'm saying.
I don't want any milk in
there cause It's the taste of
cereal as it is.
- But if you just put a little
bit of milk, we just a we.
- Bit it, yeah.
It brings out the flavor.
- Literally put the bare
minimum milk if I do.
And then I just keep rinsing
it through the milk. Yeah.
- That's exactly what I did.
So that by the time you finish it,
you only have a tiny pool of milk.
- Do you think it tastes better
with the milk in it though?
- I just cause most of the
time when it's in no milk,
I'm tired by the end of eating.
- I mean, not that I,
not that I really eat cereal
a lot of cereal anymore,
but yeah, every time I do fell a cereal,
I just it's it's milk.
- I just is cereal that good for you?
I just feel cereal is
you don't need it that much.
- Oh it depends on the cereal.
- It depends on the cereal.
- A bowl of fruit loops.
Isn't gonna be
- Brand is pretty good. Right?
I brand flakes. Yeah.
Brand flakes good.
But then I bought this brand
flakes in Japan and it had
fruit in it.
And so I was oh, okay, this sounds nice.
It's got dried.
I like that.
And then I look at the
back of the package,
I'm like a normal serving
contains 50 grams of sugar.
What are they putting in this.
- I think that's why I
stopped eating cereal.
Not just because I started
to not get hungry in the
mornings as I got older.
It's so bad for you.
- A lot of it is depends.
- The cereal you, it depends
on the cereal that you.
- Buy. I mean, yeah.
I'm sure, if you're
eating a bowl of weetbix,
weetbix, right.
Then yeah.
Obviously that's got a
lot of, health benefits,
but also I don't wanna start
my morning with wet cardboard
in my mouth.
I just don't wanna start a morning that.
- I'm sorry maybe you
just hate weebix joking.
- I do I hate it.
I feel maybe there's just no saving,
even with milk or without milk,
it just tastes
- To you I'm going to
be so non Australian.
When I say this,
I hate weetabix.
It's it's and people are yeah, just
but you can just add sugar or yogurt or
other things into it.
I then that kind of takes
away from the health benefit.
- Just gimme the yogurt.
Just I try.
Just, yeah.
- I'll just eat a top of yogurt.
That's fine see, for me,
cereal has always been,
even now as I see it's always,
I've always felt that it
feels like a snack. Right?
Cause to me people have told
me that they can't get full
having cereal without milk.
And I'm just well, to me,
I'm not even that hungry in breakfast,
to me cereal's just a quick
snack before we get to lunch.
That's your chat in.
- In my lifetime.
I think I've eaten more cereal
past 1:00 AM than I actually
have in the morning.
it is the most perfect midnight snack to.
- I really don't like eating
cereal in the evenings.
- Well what about later night?
As a midnight snack?
- No I always is actually really good.
- At midnight.
I wish Id it
cause then I feel that opens
a lot of possibilities to
my midnight snacking options.
Unfortunately I.
- Dunno well, you snack
at midnight then what?
What's your go to midnight snack.
- I try to avoid it. Obviously
it all costs crisps crisp.
- But I mean what wrong
with that? Which one with.
- It's just the most British
thing you've ever said.
- I love Chris.
- I should've seen this one coming up.
I was like searching
through the recesses of
my mind to think I know Connor.
What would he say?
And I'm of course it would be.
- Chris. I can love Chris.
- You eat that as a meal though?
- No sometimes For.
- Now seen, I've seen sweet.
I've seen you eat Doritos as a meal.
Don't lie to me.
There's no other choice doritos.
- I dunno, man.
There's always a choice that choice.
- Doritos I don't feel good about it,
but I do it. Why?
- They're good but I couldn't,
no matter how full I get
from eating just a burritos.
I can't in my head.
I can't process that as this is my meal.
I do it and it doesn't feel a meal,
but I'm just so full that it's
this will last till morning.
So I mean I'm sure it will.
- And then in a lot of pain,
but it's pretty good.
- I've been there.
Don't worry I've been there.
- Yeah I'm not a big cereal guy.
I've don't eve neat.
- Did you eat it as a kid?
Cause I can't remember.
Cause I used to eat it a lot
as a kid and I don't remember
the exact point that I
stopped eating cereal.
- I swapped to toast
when I was a kid halfway
through school, I must have
decided that I preferred toast.
So I'd eat four pieces of toast.
- I think I had a very brief period
from to toast and then it
just very quickly went
from toast to nothing.
- But I feel like toast and
cereal are in the same category
of not very good nutritional value,
but it's not the worst thing in the world.
It's not bad, but it's also not great.
- Actually the moment I,
I actually know the moment
I switched from toast to no
breakfast was when I started
having coffees in the morning.
- No tea for me tea.
Just having a piece of
toast with a hot drink.
You can't beat it. Not even
that for me, it was just
just replace the toast
with a cup of coffee.
- Wait what?
- I do that now.
- I do that now as well.
But from I'd say for me,
maybe 17, 18, I was just yep.
Coffee that's all I need.
- I Woody toast in Japan,
but the bread sucks.
And the other place you get
good bread from is bakeries.
- And they're stupidly expensive.
- It's 50 bucks for a slice of bread.
- What irks me about a lot
about the normal Japanese
bread that they sell supermarkets.
It's just how thick it is.
- It's insane.
It could barely fit my toaster.
- That's true I'm not gonna lie.
I think this is gonna make
me sound privileged as.
Yeah, I don't wanna cut the bread.
I wanna just Chuck that in the toaster.
I've just woken up. Right?
I don't wanna have to get the bread board
out the bread knife out.
Oh, it's too thick.
Oh, I've caught it badly.
I just want the perfect slide.
This is not a privilege thing.
This is just a.
- Absolutely a privilege thing.
- What are you on?
- This is why they say the best invention
since slice spread.
- It's literally a human revolution.
Don't you just want to
just, do you really?
Do you really.
- Want what slice spread
really? That revolutionary.
I want that the, well the yeah.
I wanna know why I've
never thought about the,
actually the history of that saying it.
- Literally takes 10 seconds.
- To, but it's not,
it's not the act of cutting it.
It's the cleaning up.
I have to clean up a
breadboard, a bread knife.
Now just for one slice of bread.
if I just have the slice bread,
I Chuck that in have.
- What about if you just buy
the loaf of bread, for example,
the unco loaf of bread.
No, on that day you
slice it up preemptively.
You put it back in the bag
and now you've got sliced.
- No you.
- Can't do that.
That's I did that.
- No, that's up.
- I can't really relate.
- You speed run it going bad.
- No, cause I.
- Yeah, I don't think
I've ever bought breads.
That's not been pre sliced now
that I about it in my life.
See, at least wow.
Privilege is showing.
They call me privilege
for slice of my bread.
At least I've done the
legwork I've been there.
I've been in the trenches
slice of my own bread.
- I've lived that life.
- I've lived a life of I've.
- On that now.
- it's aside, baguettes or whatever.
I've never actually sliced my own wow.
Loaf of bread.
Call me privilege.
- Ed it's upper classes, season writing.
- This is the opposite of
people from England
have never cooked their
own rice or something me and Asian.
I've never sliced my own bread before.
- So there is a bakery
near me that I really
but the loaf of bread
is six bucks I think.
- How big half is standard.
- Sizes only that.
- Yeah. Okay.
Half a standard size.
I'm sure it's great.
I just don't wanna pay six bucks for half,
half my life.
- I've had. Yeah.
Because my, and I have to cut it.
- Ron. Oh, me.
- For six bucks,
I'm not cutting that.
That's ridiculous.
- For, I mean, I thought that as well,
but then at my previous
place we lived right next to
this really high end
bakery anda full loaf,
this big was nine bucks or something,
which is ode, still.
- Still expensive.
And I thought it was just
a scam being oh, just,
this is just Japanese people.
- People it's this is
just Japanese people.
Not knowing good bread.
But then and I bought it and I had it and
I had to slice it myself.
God forbid I had to
slice it myself and yeah.
I made toast with it and I'm okay,
I can see why this is nine bucks.
- No.
It was amazing.
It was very good brand.
But it was not no, amount.
I wouldn't pay nine bucks for that.
Outside of Japan is what I'm saying.
- Why would you pay for inside Japan?
- Because every other
bread in Japan sucks.
- It's fair enough. And it's
look, don't get me wrong.
I'm not buying this every day
for me, this loaf of bread.
I would this $9 loaf of bread
I would buy was maybe once
every couple of months.
- How good was that?
In terms of bread in general,
this $9 bread compared to if you.
- Were, it was good.
it was better than any super get bread.
I would buy in Australia or anywhere
outside of Japan.
So it was oh.
- I've had the same bread.
Cause I bought it.
It was good.
It was really, really good.
I was okay, this actually tastes here.
This is actually some top tier.
this is some a.
- How does it compare to
say the bread in Europe?
- I think the bread that I had in France
in Germany was better.
- Well, yeah
- Obviously that's,
I'm asking how much better was
it than this top tier bread,
top tier $9 bread that we have brought.
- In the know, marginally,
it got to that taste
where it was just good.
it was very good.
But then that the one in
Germany or France will cost
one Euro 50 or two Euro.
- Obviously. Yeah.
It's not even, I mean, opposite.
So with rice, right?
And if you're having rice in Europe,
then obviously the one in
Japan's gonna taste better just
- cause you know, in
the UK it was what we're
pound for Warton?
Was it Warton is the toast
bread. I love that toast bread.
- It is very good bread.
Oh that I would know it.
- And even in the UK, right.
When you buy.
- The animals when you buy the loaf bread
at the supermarket,
the one that isn't cut,
can you cut it for me?
- I'll put it in.
You can buy uncut bread
at the supermarket.
- We have bakery.
We have bakeries.
And where bakeries in the supermarkets.
- Gone do what a bakeries?
- There's a bakery. Right?
And then when you get your pastries,
whatever, they all sell loafs of bread.
- Ive pastries I've never
seen a loaf of bread.
- Yeah. They have it.
And if you want the loaf of
bread, uncut, you can buy.
Who does that?
Who ask for that?
- A lot of people do.
Cause a lot of people if
they're making their own stuff,
then it's not a big deal
that they're cutting it.
Cause they want it fresh.
Cause the moment you cut it,
the time is ticking.
It's already going bad, right?
That's why you don't want
to cut the whole bread.
Then put it back in.
Cause then those slices
that might have tasted a bit fresher.
Two, three days are gonna be rock solid.
Did you never put your
bread in the freezer?
- What!
- No cause that's the way to make bread.
Long lasting that's what
we used to in Australia.
- I'm sure if you cryogenic
it last longer as well.
- I mean, this is not.
- What the did you just say Joey?
- That's an American thing.
We don't do that in Europe.
- It's up. We do it in Australia as well.
- That's up.
- We do it in,
we do it in south.
Gets to preserve.
- Exactly. It's the 1000 degrees.
- It's to make the bread last longer.
That's putting ice in beer.
You, the you just don't do.
- And You gotta understand the
loaf for bread in the UK and
in Europe it's bought on the day intended
to all be used on that day.
It's not supposed to be,
obviously you can have it a day over.
That's not a big deal,
but you don't freeze the bread's because
because the Australian loves the bread.
There's 20 slices.
So even a family,
can't go through it ina day.
How big is this bread this,
- But just buy a small.
- This a lover bread's
- Yeah, no.
It's this big or 20 slices in it.
So obviously 20.
- Slices does it taste as.
- Good I want an image of this.
I image exactly.
I need an image of Australian bread.
- But yeah.
- What you, I don't believe this.
It's the big foot of
bread. This can't be real.
- So just to make the
bread last little bit,
little bit longer because you don't wanna
have loafs of bread every day.
Especially if you're
living in my household,
which was kind of half rice, half bread.
I'm not
This I'm not even the bread guy.
- Well, that's the size of the UK one.
- But they're way thinner.
- Oh, they're needier.
- Yeah. But anyway, so yeah.
To make the bread last longer,
we would use the slices
we needed to use on the day we buy it.
And then we,
it would immediately go to
the freezer because the last,
an extra two, three weeks,
and then you just,
and if you wanna a slice
of bread, you grab it.
obviously it's frozen because
it's been in the freezer,
you throw it into the toaster
instantly defrosted taste.
- Just, I'm not even the bread guy.
And I would never put myself
down to such savagery as
putting a bread in the freezer.
- Well I'm sorry you hire privileged.
People could buy bread
whenever you wanted.
My family was saving money.
- Your family had a
financial advisor show.
What you talking about?
- And our financial advisor
was freeze your bread.
- We gotta change somethings around here.
- You want, do you want that?
Do you want that new apartment?
You better freeze your God bread boy.
- Asian mentality.
- Put everything in the
freezer last longer.
Save money, exactly.
- No, I think this is.
Just your excuses for living like savages.
- We're Australian.
- If it was something oh,
we don't want the spiders to get it.
Well that too.
No because you get a bread bin.
- No, because the bread bin would be
annihilated by the ants.
What? Yeah.
Cause we are in Australia.
You can't escape from the wildlife.
You leave the door open
for one second too long.
Your house is.
Over rid by ants in summer.
- The one thing that makes me
not proud to be Thai is one
thing that they do.
And I just said it,
they put ice in their beer disgusting.
And it's, I mean,
I see the logic because obviously it's
30, 35 degree weather.
Beer's gonna get warm.
Beer's gonna get warm a lot faster.
But even me,
I'm just no, no ice.
My beer please.
No we're not gonna go down.
- Is that an option you
can get at any restaurant.
- They normally or is
that a backyard thing?
- No.
By default in Thailand
in a lot of restaurants,
especially if it's open air, right?
You order a beer.
They take a cartel.
They give you the beer
and they give you a glass and they
put ice in it.
And then they pour the beer
in the glass for the ice.
And you have you specifically
ask in a lot of places for
them not to do that. Right.
- It's probably trying to hide the beer.
- Is there anything
worse than watered down?
Thai beer water.
- Nightmare I mean, you see,
you do that with a charm beer
and it's just like this beer
was already watered down
and you're watering it down even more.
- Beer flavored water at that.
- Point. Sorry you oven washing this.
- German's had a heart
attack listening to that.
the Fu but I've never,
put bread in the freezer.
I'll say that we've never
- Hey man, you.
- I'm not doing that.
- I'm not saying you should.
I was just saying that's what we did.
And I thought it was normal.
- Do you have to put eggs in the fridge?
I can't remember where
I heard it from where
if you have to put some
things in the fridge or some
things are fine being left.
- It depends on the country
and how it's cleaned.
I believe in some places in Europe,
they recommend you not to fridge the eggs.
Can you Google this?
If I'm recall correctly,
I think we didn't keep
our eggs in the fridge
when I was growing up.
I don't think we did.
- I don't think we did either.
- In Japan you're
supposed to keep the eggs
in the fridge or I don't think it.
- Yeah, you have to, or yeah,
you have to keep it in the fridge.
- European countries say you do not have.
- To keep that's right.
That's right really that's right.
Cause I don't, we had it in a cupboard.
- Really? Yeah.
Oh, that's weird.
And in America I think
they put it in the fridge.
I think, I dunno about Japan.
- I don't know.
As someone who's was just born of
just kind of,
every time I went shopping with my mom
and we'd buy eggs.
The moment she'd open the front door,
she'd be like eggs in the fridge now.
- Apparently it's illegal to what
eggs in Europe so got stuff.
- Illegal so you're putting
the fridge actually gonna grow.
- Back to your, what?
The egg police are gonna
rock up to my door,
but you're ah.
- Police I think it means for that
transporting it and stuff.
Not that you go home.
- Yeah, we don't.
We kept them in the cupboard.
I remember that. Yeah.
- Yeah bread. We've never
put in the fridge eggs.
We've never put in the fridge potatoes.
I don't think we've ever.
- No potatoes were in the pantry for.
- Because I think if
you put in the fridge,
it grows sprouts right.
- I don't know.
Or some thing that.
I don't know.
I know potatoes.
You're not supposed to put
in the fridge and onions.
I think.
Cause I feel rules different
with a different country.
I go to cause in Thailand,
it's just 90% of everything
goes in the fridge.
Cause it's so much hotter there.
- Obviously it's hot.
It goes in the fridge.
- Yeah hot and humid is not the best in.
- Well that's the best,
best temperature and
conditions for bacteria.
So yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But other things you
shouldn't chocolate,
you're not supposed to put in the fridge.
- I know I putting
chocolate in the fridge.
Wait, why do you.
- Why, I think it's
because if you put
chocolate in the fridge,
then it turns white.
And that just means that it's gone bad.
- What I've never seen I
chocolate in the fridge.
This sounds some I love have
my chocolate hard into yeah.
- White stuff is not that
the chocolate done out.
It's just some other.
- Stuff, what is that?
Some other stuff I'm worried.
- I don't know.
I always heard chocolate.
I always heard you shouldn't
put chocolate in the fridge for
too long or you could,
you can't let it in the fridge.
I don't know.
Maybe that's just me.
- It's either sugar or
fat, but it's not that the.
- Chocolates. Oh, okay.
- Yeah I definitely prefer
my chocolate in the fridge.
There's two states of chocolate that are
my favorite one is just
in the fridge it's hard.
You get a nice, nice crunchy bite of it.
And the second stage would
where it's a cheaper chocolate.
When it's perfectly room temperature,
but not melted.
- When you put in your
mouth, it easily melt.
- You put it in your
mouth and it doesn't melt,
but it just dissolves in your mouth.
That's that's my second favorite.
I don't of chocolate.
- It's not that. It's it
gets all over your gums.
You're when it's, you don't.
- Even need to chew at that point.
You put it, melt.
- Just disintegrate.
- I don't want it to do.
- That's a, don't it sit?
- I when it's cold, you can chew into it.
And its naps apart and breaks into
nice chocolate bites.
- I that I don't that too much
because I've had some instances
where I'm what's gonna break first,
the chocolate or my teeth.
I don't wanna find out.
- There are some chocolates
that are way too hard.
For that there are some,
I mean the caramel bars I've
never put in the fridge.
- Oh my gosh.
- If you put hard caramel on the fridge,
goodbye teeth, your teeth.
- It's just literally
jaw break is just eating.
- Rocks at that point.
- Yeah. What about ice cream?
Do you do you like your ice
cream? hard or soft serve?
Do you like biting into your ice cream?
Hard yeah.
lollies, do you
- That's on ice cream then.
- Yeah.
- That's I guess.
- That's an ice block.
Your ice cream hard or soft?
- Well, you've had feasts right where it's
it's an ice cream on, feast where it's
got a chocolate in the middle
and it's ice cream around it.
- Oh, you mean oh, that's more of a, oh,
that's not so much ice cream though.
That's more of ice cream bar.
I'd say it's more of a cause
it's got a layer around it.
- Cause I know a lot of
people they cannot take.
they cannot chew on hold things or really
cool things At all.
Yeah. Can you not?
No, I love it too much.
Where if I start chewing ice.
- I always hear you're
you'll be talking to someone you'll hear
you just look at it's ground.
I'm not guy it's gone.
It's God's not even looking.
You just staring off to the distance,
doing it crunching.
- I love crunching on ice God.
- It's the best texture.
I love it.
I dunno why I just, yeah.
It's not good for my teeth at all no.
I've been told by my dentist
and pretty much everyone around
me to not do that,
but there will be times where,
I literally have to
consciously not put ices
in my drinks now
because I do it so much
that everyone's advised
me to not do it.
- Is that the real reason
why you don't put ice in your beer?
- I don't wanna ice, man the beer.
- Have you been in the social situation
or you're drinking your
drink and then you're right.
I'm gonna, I'm going to take this ice.
I'm gonna put it in my mouth.
But the cubes a little too big
and your mouth's really cold,
but it's in your mouth.
And it's in there.
It's in one of your cheeks and
your thing is freezing.
And you have that moment where you're
if I you're talking to someone,
you don't wanna look weirdo.
You're if I bite into this,
it's gonna look weird.
But if I swallow this,
I might choke and look weird.
So what do I do?
I need to reply in 10 seconds
and they stop speaking.
Do I spit the ice back in the
drink and looks like weirdo?
Cause if I go,
so you were safe.
Have you been in that situation?
- Yeah, many times.
- And I'm like my go-to option is normally
just pray that you can
swallow this without dying.
Just pray.
- Really?
No, my option is to just
start crunching on that.
- I mean, that's.
- The least weird one.
- Yeah. That is.
- The least weird one. I've
never had an issue because
I'm constantly crunching.
- Anyway, I can't crunch it.
I'm always definitely worried
that they're just gonna think I'm a
weirdo when I spit it
back in, but I can't.
Yeah. Cause if you spit it back in,
they're what the?
- Spitting it back in
biggest is the worst.
Not, but my teeth can't bite into.
- It, but I also don't wanna be that guy.
Who's so I've been in situation before.
- Keep throwing an ice.
- Where I'm all right, boys, here we go.
This might be it.
I might be dead.
- But how many ice cubes have
you swallowed in your life?
uncountable, uncountable.
- Moments, over 10.
- That a lot normally I would just try and
- Kind of what's your.
- We kind of try and
move it around to get it
to a swallowable size.
Right.
Or maybe not as.
- Fast as you can or maybe just get it
so that it doesn't have harsh edges.
- You swallowed ice cubes with hard edges.
- Where they're full, cute.
- No way.
No way.
- I would be so terrified to.
- Normally the technique,
but the problem is that this
is where the technique fails is
that I'm normally doing
this after I've drank it.
So now I can't use water
to assist it flowing
when I swallow.
So I have to just swallow a dry ice cube.
- I was saying that
you just take a swig of
water or something that
will help that would help melt it a bit.
- I just swallow it and yeah,
one time I think I had a
really big scare one time.
Cause got stuck,
but I remember I had to play it.
Cause I was I don't wanna make
them do a, he maneuver on me.
So I would just kind of keep
Keep trying to swallow
it before I take a breath
and then eventually it
went down and oh my God,
my esophagus was in so much pain. Yeah.
And by the way,
never risk your life for a bit of social
or witness just,
I should have just spatted out.
But yeah, it was,
it was terrifying.
- Just chewing it a.
- Real, I could feel it.
Cause it was so big.
I could feel it going down
and then getting stuck
a little bit sometimes.
And then waiting.
And then obviously it was
cause obviously my body's really warm.
So it would slowly dissolve.
- So You just gave you
esophagus freeze burn or.
- It hurt so much.
- Yeah, no.
- Don't do that.
The lengths that British person
will go to not be awkward in
the social circumstance, just.
- Spit it out at appointment just.
- Just spit it out.
- What I was playing the most.
- I will say if I didn't
love chewing on ice so much,
I would probably do the same thing.
- I don't wanna,
I would rather potentially risk
having a choking incident as
opposed to having 10 seconds
of social awkward interaction.
That's what I really, yeah.
That's the British and me,
we just can't we can't do it.
- I don't know, man.
just yeah.
It's it's.
- Can't yeah, it's gonna be weird.
Speeding your ice back
your drink or whatever.
But I don't know how many
situations can you think of where
you've say been to dinner
with some other person, right?
Or what's the first date. Right?
First date with someone.
- First day, for example.
Right? If you're on a first
day with someone, right?
How many times have you gone
to a restaurant with say
another, a lady.
Right. And she's gone anyway.
Yeah. And then that, at that point,
your head's no.
- Wait, I, part of me partly would be
- When is, when is spitting.
- Ice back in your glass?
The game changer.
- I'm not gonna lie.
It's one of probably the least
attractive things you can do.
It looks very unattractive.
Don't you think?
So someone should.
- I think so.
I think something that's less attractive.
- You choking on an ice?
- You go no on a date.
That's good show.
No, I wouldn't.
I've actually been in the
situation four actually.
Not and I haven't swallowed it.
I've just, I just remembered.
- It's on a date you want,
they wanna know that you
swallow and your wellness.
- Show I wanna.
- Oh my God are you.
- They didn't even notice it.
They didn't even know
that you just swallowed.
- And they probably would've.
They can see my Adams,
apple and marching times.
I'm I do it.
My chest is
- No, it's the tissue technique.
It's the tissue technique.
- Because not for a big ice cube.
They're gonna see your
tissue on the table.
No, it's gonna be a.
- You don't put it back on the table.
You go for the tissue.
You pretend you're just
wiping your mouth or whatever.
You're just you salt.
The I'm gonna,
- You've gotta be salt because
now they're gonna think, oh,
this guy just choked out a massive Louie.
- In front of me.
- This ice cube, this, this ice cube.
- Are you talking when you,
when you exude an exude,
when you take out on ice cube
out your mouth, you don't go.
- No, no.
God, this was, this was maybe a what?
- How big of the ice cube were we talking?
- This is a four centimeter cubes.
A four by four by four
by four centimeters.
Let's say that's a big.
- Ice cube.
- Dude..
That's what I'm talking.
- Okay.
No if it's that size,
I never take the risk of putting.
- It in my mouth. I'm not
putting it in my mouth.
- I was dumb.
I don't know why I.
- Did cause caus eat that point,
right at that point you
probably would've hardly
even drank your drink.
- Huh? I'm the speed.
It's gone let say it's a bang in cocktail.
it's an absolute winner.
Yeah. I love the cocktail so much.
Or maybe, I wanna order a bunch more.
I wanna try for more.
So I drink it all and the ice cubes
are still fully formed because.
- At that point,
the ice cube just doesn't feel nice.
Three if.
- You can feel the
edges on the ice cube it
doesn't feel nice in your mouth.
- I thought when you say,
when you swallow ice cubes,
I thought you were talking about
when you buy a drink at
McDonald's or something.
- Are you swallowing whiskey rocks?
- No. No. It was I can't
remember which one it was
- You're literally swallowing, whiskey,
- Ice cube. It, it was a
Fullon formed ice cube.
it was a nice ice cube.
That's why I wanted to put
it in my mouth because I was,
I remember, I honestly, I was.
- But I can get this down.
- I was, yeah. I'd been
training for a while.
I was I was 19.
I was, thinking I was fancy probably.
I don't know what I
remember the exact scenario.
I remember this specific scenario.
The reason why I was so
committed to potentially dying,
to avoid social awkwardness.
It was because I was a first
date and I was very nervous
and she was very attractive.
I really wanted this to go well.
- And so you were I'm a eat this ice cube.
- And so some reason I
think the 19 year old,
was tapping into the fit 15,
12 year old to me that was
that ice cube looks real
because sometimes you see an ice cube
and you just put it in your mouth.
Cause you are of course.
Cause you're dumb when
you're a kid and you want,
of course I, now I have no desire.
- It really depends. Okay.
It really depends as someone
who has eaten a lot of ice
cubes in my life, an ice cube.
- As the ice cube cone I saw here,
so many different factors. Right?
Because sometimes, sometimes it's big,
but for some reason it's hollow inside.
So you can take a good,
you can Sometimes its
just completely solid.
It's just a solid block
of solid block of ice.
And there is not here is no
biting down on that unless
it's at least a little bit melted.
At all.
And at that point it's gonna
take at least one or two
minutes, regardless of the social, social.
- Situ I started doing the
grinding technique awful.
- Yeah. It's awful for my teeth,
but I take one bite and I'm oh okay.
This isn't a hollow one.
No, all right.
Switch to space.
Two grinding technique.
- I remember it was quite a hefty boy.
It was a waity boy.
Hence why again? I wanted
to put it in my mouth.
It looks, it looked.
- I want all the Trash Taste saids
of this taken outta context.
- It looked too good not
to allow it to go to waste.
So I had to of.
- Course, yeah.
- For me it's the opposite
for me. If it's perfectly,
the edges are perfectly rounded.
That's peak ice.
That's peak ice to put in your
mouth that is peak ice to put
in your mouth and it cause it all.
- Straight away with the giant balls,
the whiskey car's.
- No joke every time I get
recommended a video of one
of the waiters, shaving ice.
Yeah. It's one it's the most
satisfy rooms in my life.
- Whole need to say,
I don't wanna put it in my
mouth cause I don't wanna die.
Oh yes I, yeah.
I've learned my lesson.
I'm not with that.
It was all.
- Also clear ice, superior ice,
superior ice to the
frosted ice that you get
where it's clear outside
and frosted in the middle.
There's trashed here, ice.
- Isn't that?
Get that out. This is
just level one bartending.
- I mean just I think difference to chew,
to chew on well to chew on.
Yeah. Sorry I'm just this
is my five year old brain.
- This is right now my
favorite crayons taste level of
conversation. It's I like the maroon one.
- I like cherry red because
it's got the word te.
- Ju prefer ju prefer cube dice.
Or how do you feel about.
- Don't have a.
- No, no.
Cause I know a lot of
people who hate crush dice.
- Oh yes. Okay.
Actually. Yeah.
I do hate crush.
- I really crush.
- I crushed dice. Yeah.
- Why did you it's a slushy.
- You get okay so you,
everyone knows my soda take right where I,
I like it.
That's the wrong one.
I just, I it where,
you take a little bit of the fizz out and
to me crushed dice has
more of a surface area to,
just to just make soda,
the perfect texture, the perfect flavor.
If you drink it with out a straw, right?
- No it is great because
if you drink it with,
without a straw,
then you get a lot of crushed
dice and you can chew it.
- It's perfect.
- You get the best of both worlds.
- It's just this is you're yeah.
I don't they bring extra,
extra colors in the crown
package, which can eat.
- One of them To draw.
This wants to eat.
- This is I don't want
to taste the ice slush in my mouth.
I want to taste the drink being cold.
This is why when we go
to Denny's in Japan,
I hate their Iceman machine.
The ice is always the the shaved ice.
Yeah. And you drink it and you just get
a mouth full of shaved ice.
When you gotta do that
technique where you're
- I won putting it in my mouth.
Oh my God.
I like it when it's at
the bottom of the glass
and then you do this and then just, oh my.
- But it's the last
little bit where you get.
- Flavor it's basically
just shaved ice it bit more.
- The bottom it stay at the top.
- I mean you go gotta drink it.
You go I mean it depends
because have you've hung out with me.
So you've seen how much shave.
- Hung out with.
- You've seen how much
shaved dice I put into there.
Minimum the minimum amount of shaved ice.
I put into a cup.
If I have the choice is half the cup.
That's the minimum for me.
- This is right. When Gar
goes to the moody theater,
he's wow, look how much value I'm going?
I've drank four drinks today.
He's no, can't you've drank.
- Buy this man buys chips and goes can.
- To me the saddest sight
I've I ever see in my life.
Is when you go to a shaved
ice machine and people put
a bit in a tiny bit,
5% of the cup.
- I do 1% most I put any.
- And then you,
fill up with the soda, right?
I'd rather people put no in,
because you fill out
with the soda, the saddest sight.
It's just seeing one
or two bits of ice just
floating around in the
soda that's doing nothing.
It's literally do nothing.
Why would you put ice in?
If it's all the ice you're gonna put in.
- I'm not even in a cap.
I've never given a.
I've never been seething
rage me God damn it.
- I have cause you can't
even chew on the ice.
That's why next.
- Why it doesn't matter.
Cause it's gonna probably gonna melt.
- I'm the point I'm gonna
predict God's next take.
He thinks that soup should be
exclusively eaten with straws.
- No, I don't.
I don't think.
- It's just a drink.
- Isn't it?
He's a drink.
Super a drink quick.
So less rusty.
- Less rusty Curry is a drink.
- I want clown take you
to come out with next.
- I'm collecting them right now.
Just gimme more food to infinity.
- Stones of Taste Christ.
- Taste can be whatever I want them to be.
- I think it's only a
Southeast Asian thing. Right?
Where you can
you buy a soda at a stand or something.
I dunno if I've told this story before,
but you buy a soda at stand or something
and then they will
serve it to you in a plastic bag.
Is that Southeast? Is that so yes.
Yes can they.
- So can they not afford
plastic containers
or is this an artistic choice?
- I don't know why it is right.
But I remember the first time, like.
- That's as weird as a Bag.
Then I remember the first time,
because I thought this was a normal thing.
Because when I was a kid,
I'd go to a
Thailand every year and one of especially
hot day you'd you'd go
to a stand you'd order,
a soft drink.
And what happens is they
will have a glass bottle
and then they will.
That, but that.
So what happens is they
will have a glass bottle,
whatever soda you order,
they'll uncap it.
And then they'll take a plastic bag out,
just put in that ton of vice
in the bag and just pour
the soda into the bag.
I'll give it to you.
- Doesn't sound that bad.
- Actually. That's actually quite cool.
- Give you a Comly large straw.
- They just give you a straw.
- They give you a TWI straw with.
- So what happens?
Let's say you're well.
this is a lot of soda.
how much we talking? Is it
a normal can doing 30 mil?
- Yeah.
- Normal can, right?
Let's say you are halfway
through the can. You're oh,
I wanna just put it down for a second.
- Can put it down when
you hang up, my drink.
- Do have to find a hanger.
- How do I put.
- It down? Yeah.
So a lot of restaurants
will have these little,
little hangers on the table or something.
That's actually.
- Kind of cool.
- You could.
- Just hang below the table.
- You could just hang the soda on.
- Yeah. So if you wanna be excuse me.
- Anyway.
- And Laurie drivers in
Singapore would have hope.
- That's true.
I complete for got about,
they got the hooks as.
- Well. Okay.
Question then cause we were
talking about chewing on ice.
How the do you chew the
ice from a plastic back?
- Oh, he shovels it with.
- His hands you just
grab it with your hand
because you can't you
can't do this. Right.
- When you're after you've done drinking,
so you take the plastic, you get,
you can actually just
take one by one and just
and or you take the straw and you just
so you scoop a little bit up also.
- These brand new plastic
bags or these reuse from
the guys, grocery shopping.
- You combine.
- You got the Al bag bro.
I'm using little bro.
- I've never really thought
about that until yeah.
- I wanna knowhow clean that.
- Yeah. I'd be very concerned
if he just whips outsome
crushed one from somewhere I'm
- Found a part of Southeast Asian culture
that we don't normally talk about.
I realize cause.
- It's is a good drink.
- It's I surely.
- I know this is complete
nostalgia talking,
but I like the way that.
- Oh yeah.
- Amount of plastic in a bag
is enough to make one cup.
No. What do you mean?
surely you can make a cup from one bag.
- It's thinner.
It's thinner, right?
- Yeah but plastic bags are.
- What I, no,
what I wanna know is
why do they not just give you the bottle?
- Yeah. Why that, because
you're on the ice.
- Why do they have to,
to grab the bottle and
empty it into a bow?
Why can't they just give you the bottle?
- I believe because they
just recycle the bottles.
- Okay. So they send them back off.
I believe that's.
That's sorry.
- That's you can get a lot
of drinks in south Asia.
They come a tub.
So they scoop it up.
- Into, but surely the plastic.
The plastic use on all those plastic.
You could just convert into one cup.
There's a lot of plastic
in one plastic bag.
As, as the turtles.
Well know.
- Oh no. I don't I think,
I don't think a lot of
Southeast Asian countries at the
moment have much awareness
about plastic and trying to
reduce the amount of plastic.
I remember I'm just generally curious.
How, why it was.
- Sized back.
I just genuinely think that
that's just how it's been.
some dude was just one day was just
what if we put it.
- I dunno, plastic back.
- That still be hilarious.
It's a spread.
I could be show ignorance with that,
but I'm just surely there's a better way.
- I'm sure there is.
But there is obviously
we are very wasteful
with our cups and stuff.
We line Starbucks cups, wax
and maybe they just,
I dunno, maybe they just don't give a.
They're just I just want my drink.
I don't care what it's in.
- I guess, I would be
- Well, maybe they,
are thinking in a recycling manner
where after they finish the drink,
they'll be right after the supermarket.
Just what?
Fold it inside out.
- All right.
- Brand new there we go.
- All my groceries. So right.
So you have a car, right?
The just cup holders is useless.
You just or is it just
- We don't use car.
So you just hanging it up
on the what's the thing.
- Bro God forbid you
get a bump in that car.
You go is.
- Coke all over.
You just go over a patchy bit.
Your coke is coming out sake.
I should have tied it up.
- She a double, no, that.
- You just ordered your
triple latte from Starbucks
and you're going up the mountain road.
- It's oh, just Christ.
Well no, what's the
worst is what if you are,
just walking along and then you happen to
Nick onto something.
And then the there's a tear in the bag
and you and you.
- Are spilling out.
Then you're just.
- You got a shotgun that has
happened before you just.
- It's something about a cup.
I think we got it right.
A few thousand years ago.
I think we got it right?
- Comfort invented for a reason.
- I think the cup is pretty good.
I don't wanna sound an.
I'm not trying to be your culture.
- I'm not saying it's the next
best thing after slice bread
or anything, but it's pretty good.
- Sure the cup came before the wheel.
that was we had made it good.
Right then man, the
cylindrical can, right.
That, was the best invention.
Right, I've seen that YouTube video.
I think everyone I've seen that.
- 13 Million views.
That guy going that's a pretty
neat invention actually.
It's the pressure is designed.
Okay. We, again.
- We get it. You watch.
- YouTube. Yes.
Speak of YouTube.
- Show, British.
- Speak of YouTube.
I've been YouTube.
I've been watching a few
more YouTube shorts recently.
Even I know every time I go on a
YouTube shorts binge
it's bad for my health.
there's it's to me
watching YouTube shorts.
So watching Tik Tok is the
equivalent of eating McDonald's
or eating fast food.
I know I shouldn't do, but sometimes,
sometimes just lying in bed
and you just scroll
through and you're you.
- Want that quick meal?
- And you're 30 minutes have pass.
And I've consumed nothing.
So I've fallen down to,
I fell down into this hole of life advice,
YouTube or hack YouTube shots.
Oh no, I've been there.
Yeah. And it's just
remember before where we went through
that life hack phase
of Buzzfeed videos.
Well the hack,
isn't actually a hack.
So I thought that died out.
But apparently that just
went to TikTok. Yeah.
Right. Cause I remember I saw,
I saw a few career hacks
of things you can do in
to help you increase
your chances of getting
a job interview.
And there was this,
I think I saw that.
- And there's this to of this is how,
this is how it goes.
The job interviewer offers
you a glass of drop of water.
- I saw same thing yesterday ago. Yeah.
What is it?
The white guy.
Little yeah.
So the job interviewer
offers you a glass of water
and then you take the water
and that's the hack because the hack is,
if you take the glass of water,
when it's offered to you,
they ask you a difficult
question and you just go,
Well, you see the thing is,
and the hack was because
you have a glass of water,
it gives you more time to
think about the answer.
And I was the hack
and I was just losing my mind that
you could call this career advice
or 3000s and I'm who?
- This feels the only
time I ever see people
take a sip of water
road for the question
is the criminal trials.
when mark Zuckerberg was
being questioned on the,
by the it, yeah.
Every single question it'd be asked to go.
- He was using live hack, dude.
He was thinking about those answers.
- But I'm saying you don't
wanna look a criminal
when ask you a question
you don't wanna be going.
- I'm just,
I feel a more logical thing would be
can I just take a bit of time
to think about this answer?
- No, because you gotta seem confident.
- I'd be that is a fantastic question.
- Think the way to appropriately.
- Answer that no, you, what
if you combine it right?
You gotta combine it with the water.
That's a fantastic, what.
- What if the water doesn't
give you enough time?
Are, you just Downing
an entire Jack of water?
You're sitting there have
10 minutes just going.
- They're gone what's
your favorite food is, oh.
- Well, what if or what if you are just
you get offed the water. Right.
And you're just really thirsty.
And then you get to that
really difficult question.
You're just what do I do now?
The TikTok never told.
- Me, sir, you've gone
through three liters
of water during this interview.
I are you feeling okay?
- I would just say 99% of
life hacks or some I just
immediately forget and never
remember and will never,
ever practically use.
- Yeah absolutely so many of them,
especially when it comes to survival,
these kinds of hacks
or advice you see on TikTok.
I dunno if we've ever talked
about this on a podcast.
I think we've only talked
about it in private,
but the SHA financial advice,
which is an entire genre.
My favorite which is an entire,
I think an entire genre of
video on TikTok and YouTube
shorts now where it's
justShaq, motivational,
life advice and half
it is just taking your
paycheck and apparently ripping and hard.
So Shaq, what's the difference between
being rich and being wealthy.
It's when you're rich, you do this,
but the wealth you do this 1 millions.
- Thank you, Shaq.
I am no longer poor now.
- Shaqs I will.
- Poverty Shaq is a very
nice, guy's very generous.
He I'm sure the financial advice,
the problem is with a lot of
these financial advices on
TikTok and YouTube.
And again, I think Shaq is
somewhat guilty of this.
It assumes you are even
making enough money to save.
most people don't, aren't
able to save money.
Exactly cause we're right now.
Yeah most people spend all their paycheck.
That's how it is.
How do you then go to them
and you're just not saving enough.
You're just not saving enough that rent.
Maybe you can get rid of it.
- Who's living on minimum
wage and being oh,
- I didn't are there people
who spend irresponsibly?
Hell yeah, there are.
Is that the reason is
why everyone isn't rich.
No and no,
It was just so weird falling
into this hole of just
the, you see these TikTok
with made up scenarios where
the perfect life hack for
that scenario will pop up.
- It's always the same.
It's one guy is in this part of the frame
and he's so you want this?
And then another guy,
the other frame probably with glasses.
- Or something.
- No, no, no.
That's not how you do it. It's
literally, always like that.
And with the worst acting
and the worst script,
and then it's 20 million views and
I'm quitting my job.
- Terrible at my job.
And it's just an entire genre
that just takes place in
the damn universe.
it's just the extended
Darman universe where,
everything just works
up and cause of these
because I drank water in
my job interview, the DCU.
- The tar cinematic universe.
Oh wait,
the one that also just that
I've been getting a lot
recently off YouTube shorts
is the ones where the
ones where they take,
there's five minute
crowd off to life hacks.
And then there's always some dude, who's
I'm gonna find out if this is
actually legitimate or not.
And then they do.
And then they try themselves and
okay, what's legitimate for more.
- That's a thing.
That's a thing.
- Okay.
- I've seen.
- So many of those, so
many times where it's oh,
if you get a black marker,
you draw it on your hand
and then you take a
picture of it on flash.
Then it apparently zaps you some that.
And it's always some guy being no,
it's not factor or cap.
All right, let's try it.
Let's try and figure cap.
- My let's try and figure it out.
- My new favorite shorts or to
category is the tos that need
way more explanation
as to what's going on.
But the person doing
the video does not offer
any explanation as to
why they're doing the thing they're doing.
- What?
There was one time I watched
this TikTok and it was a guy.
He was so here's how I made
a case to carry my iPad farm.
And then he makes the case
and me and all the other comments were
why do you have an iPad farm?
- I think I've seen that.
- With the long case. Yeah.
And he made this video just
explaining how he made a
case for his iPad farm.
And I was the whole time,
why did you have an iPad farm?
- No, no, no.
He makes this iPad farm to test out.
If he could make enough
passive income, that's.
- It? Yeah.
- To justify making an iPad farm
and there are so many
layers to this TikTok
that I just want answers.
- To. I'm question.
- How are you making this money?
- First of all. Yeah.
what passive income revenue,
- What new are you doing? What
is this app you are using?
- I know there's some
people who run Spotify farms
and have tons and tons of phones.
And you play the same
song on Luke Oh, wow.
And then they get revenue from it. Oh.
But obviously you've used
a lot of electricity,
so it's kind of, there's
some things that, but yeah.
I mean, it's, again, there's
so many of these where
we are gonna do this thing or that
or you felt you just came
into the 90th episode of
a show and you're what is happening?
And the people making the
videos don't think that
anyone might need context or something.
- Just one line, let know.
Cause I know exactly what you mean though.
Cause they'll always start off the video.
We've just last time I made
DDO that could fly or something that.
And you guys have been
asking me to make this,
so I'm going to make it.
I'm just what missed.
- Got so many comments saying
that you should make it Harvard.
- I'm what have I missed
in the law of this?
how far back do I go?
And the thing is it's impossible to
try to triangulate this
when you click on their
channel or something.
Cause it's just
it's not always in
chronological order either.
I don't know.
YouTube shorts is
there's so many different holes,
you can slip down into
YouTube shorts and TikTok.
- And it's insane as well.
Because especially with
the YouTube shorts.
Cause I don't really use
TikTok, but with YouTube shorts,
it knows exactly what to recommend you
next because it's oh,
you spent one extra second on
this one shack motivational
Tik Tok that must mean you one 20 more.
- That's why some to I'm if
I watch a video that for too long I'm
Now the algorithm thing.
Now the algorithm thinks I this video
and the next 10 videos will
be something to do with that.
- I wish there was some
way to just tell YouTube.
I didn't like the video that they sent me,
but unfortunately they
removed the dislike.
- I know there's a lot of
talks of YouTube shorts
that watch and I'm I hated this video.
I wanna let them know.
I hated it without being an,
but I can't know.
So I just have to,
and I've already given them my watch time.
So I've for all YouTube notes,
that was the best experience in my life.
- The one that made me fall
down the Arabic hole for YouTube
shorts for me is I saw this one,
YouTube short of the founder of two Chan,
cause live streaming thing.
And he he's called hi Yuki.
Bu he's very,
cause he is the creator of two Chan.
He's a bit based in his opinions.
Gamer very controversial opinions.
- Using based in a negative.
- And based in a negative term.
And I just watched one because
I couldn't believe the answer.
And now my YouTube shorts are
just this Japanese dude saying
a lot of racist and controversial.
And I was I don't,
I didn't watch this because Id it.
I watched it
because I was trying to
process what the this guy was.
- Talking about well,
that's been a lot of criticism of YouTube,
Facebook and all these platforms.
They push you to the more
fringes of the content and yeah.
I mean that's one of the parts that's not.
- Yeah. I think one of the weirdest ones,
I've the, one of the weirdest genres
I've seen that's popped up
recently is we've gotten to
the point where YouTube shorts
are now commentating on YouTubers.
Oh yeah.
Where you'll beLu wig
just did this last week.
You won't believe what he did.
And I'm just
- I'm this why Sao doesn't take spar.
- Yeah.
Right I was right, cool.
I guess it's Mr.
Be just sent chocolate
bar to every influencer,
it's new slash.
- Oh my God.
I dunno, it's just so weird.
So weird it's just so weird.
Seeing all these new genres
and new types of content
pop up on, I guess a new,
for a new type of platform
and everything that.
But I don't understand it at all.
Do you think YouTube
shows gonna stick around?
Do you think it's gonna
get to a point where.
- It's going to be stuck around? So yeah.
It's gonna stick around
it's it's what it is.
But at the end of the day,
the long form content
is still very valuable.
Yes and that's what makes the money.
Of course yeah.
Until TikTok find a way to
properly monetize that platform
without paying their
creators way less than
what they deserve than.
I think long to long form
contents will be king for now.
That's us.
- That's show's we have
zero bias whatsoever.
Absolutely zero bias.
- Upload ridiculously long video to.
- You. We only upload six
hours of content a week.
- But Hey, that's just a theory.
A Trash theory.
- You can do the out.
- Well look at these patrons.
Wow look, all these patrons wonderful.
- Patrons wonder they all do this.
I'm sure.
- Do you do this?
Do you drink water?
Do you ask for water?
You drink water.
Drink your job?
- No, I don't believe in.
- It do the thing Joe do.
- The right well, Hey,
if you to support longer
form contenttrashtaste,
then consider going to a
pet on pet.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us a meeting with the sub red.
And if you head our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah.
What was this episode?
I have no clue.
- Were if we're ever in the job interview
and we are the interviewers, give.
- Two liter jog.
If they ask water,
I'm gonna say no be real.
We don't take things
easy here at Trash Taste.
You real Sigma.
- I'm doing job interview hard mode.
- All right thanks for watching guys.
All right, bye.
- See ya.
(upbeat music)